serge
on devrait peut-être un peu comme ça
quoi chers amis chers ennemis pas du
tout non
chers amis chers ennemis voilà chers
amis chers ennemis bien tu là
[Musique]
non
chers amis chers ennemis bienvenue sur
le plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission qui fait du bruit même quand
elle est finie avec nous ce soir
omar sharif plus le 11 septembre est né
ce qui serait l'équivalent tout
plus mal au coeur
ces livres qui va la télé avec annie
lemoine gilles martin chauffier gérer
mm
et lentement m
devant la passe et l'embellie ouais si
l'on me
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande de vous arrêter
guangzhou dyke
non je crois que ces normes quoi un
incroyable je vois pas qui dans cette
émission a fait de tel aplomb en
arrivant jaune en bleu je vois pas non
je pense que ça restera comme un des
meilleurs moments de cette émission je
pense qu'on pourrait leur diffusées en
boucle
lorsqu on pourrait même envoyé le
générique fin maintenant ce serait assez
bien ce serait la classe
non non vous apportez une banane oui
j'ai vu ça tout à l'heure je me suis dit
ça va servir je ne sais pas qui va la
manger mais je pense que c'est servir et
alors vous avez toujours votre votre
appareil qui vous permet de séparer des
sms et puis et puis là le dossier ne
talkie walkie pour prendre vraiment le
plateau omar et reliés à la sécurité web
maintenant c'est d'accord voilà et puis
à la carte de bons clients vous avez
fait laurent quand j'en ai plein alors
comment vous dire à quel point elles
sont données avec parcimonie
non je déconne je les prends ta garde
que proglio alors vous savez dans cette
émission maintenant il ya duplex avec le
carré viiip et dans ce carré viiip mais
oui comme la semaine dernière exactement
pareil y'a frédéric beigbeder mais c'est
très différent de la semaine dernière
oui puisque la semaine dernière
observait votre cas sur votre cas et là
bizarrement la fille rapporte que de
l'eau minérale reçoit cannes à la zone
connaît avec joie que c'est après le gag
on peut dire d'ores et déjà que frédéric
sera toujours dans la loge vip chaque
semaine
ouais et qu'il a signé un contrat pour
40 semaine toute l'année et on ne verra
jamais sur le plateau pour parler de son
bouquin exactement façon c'est vrai que
vous avez décidé de pas faire de télé
pour votre bouquin cette fois ci donc
voilà un bel je suis je suis très
discret je me cache bon le problème
c'est que la semaine dernière il y avait
pierre palmade dans cette loge c'est ça
il faut tout sur d'autres palmade
c'est incroyable un concours de boissons
j'ai perdu ça arrive
fédérer quand on retrouve tout à l'heure
bon qu'est ce qu'on fait là beigbeder
s'est terminée donc il a fait sa promo
ah bon on va passer aux premiers invités
je crois déjà
et oui c'était bien ravi de cette
semaine
il me rejoint la [ __ ]
et maintenant
[Musique]
ouais si omar sharif
[Applaudissements]
on a recherché le prince ali de lawrence
d'arabie
ça vous fait quoi quand vous écouter
cette musique là
ça ça m'énerve montpellier tuellement
entendu a plus ça me rappelle ça me
rappelle ma jeunesse que je cherche à
oublier absolument alors maintenant on
en même temps omar lawrence d'arabie
c'est le film qui marque vos débuts de
comédien internationale en 1962 et qui
fera de vous la première et la seule
star arabe d'hollywood
c'était du temps de nasser
oui ça veut dire c'est comme si
aujourd'hui quelqu'un du pays de saddam
hussein dont canirac allaient devenir
les relations entre les états unis et
nasser est pas terrible alors après et
lawrence d'arabie il ya eu docteur
jivago marco polo meilleures lignes vous
avez incarné james risque en che guevara
nicolas 2 alors aucun nouveau film ne
vous satisfait vraiment avec vous
déclarez vous dit
finalement dix secondes dans un film 10
secondes dans un autre mais globalement
il a aucun qui vous plaît vraiment il ya
des films qui me plaisent mais ils
veulent me plaît pas moi même je veux
dire par exemple j'adore lawrence
d'arabie
mais je trouve que j'aurais pu faire
mieux art est d'accord alors ça vous a
pas empêché d'être récompensé au
festival du film de venise
puisqu'on vous a décerné un lion d'or
pour l'ensemble de votre carrière donc
pour tous ces films et que vous avez pas
tellement c'était fin août et en
novembre ça recommence à hollywood de
l'american film institute pareil encore
une récompense un email pour dire ça
sent le sapin
oui exactement c'est bon c'est bien déjà
ne pas les recevoir de façon posthume à
voir de son vivant mais il faut arriver
à mon âge pour arriver à voir ces
prix-là faut avoir 71 ans et avoir
tourné 50 ans cette année c'est le 50e
anniversaire de mon premier film voilà
[Applaudissements]
alors à chacun de ces hommages votre
nouveau film ait présenté d'abord à
venise et bientôt aller où c'est un film
qui s'appelle monsieur ibrahim et les
fleurs du coran de françois dupeyron
alors on va en parler bien sûr mais
d'abord j'aimerais qu'on remonte en
arrière même si vous n'avez pas beaucoup
vous pencher sur votre passé j'aimerais
qu'on voit un peu votre histoire dont
vous êtes né à alexandrie oui voilà
d'une famille de commerçants aisés
j'étais dans le bois d'origine libanaise
syro-libanaise siro lice hier les
banques celles-ci ballade épique
alors vous êtes fils unique votre père
voulait que vous preniez sa succession
mais vous avez refusé et un jour dans un
salon de thé vous rencontrez youssef
chahine exactement grands réalisateurs
et vous faites en 53 votre premier film
ciel d'enfer qui fait de vous
immédiatement une star en egypte le film
est sélectionné au festival de cannes en
1954 et là bas vous dites j'ai été
accueilli comme un sex-symbol parlant il
se classait homosexuels c'est vrai je
lis si je les suis très tard dans ma vie
pas un copain moi qui étais très vieux
qui est mort cette année l'année passée
je crois qu'ils étaient si vous voulez
le le président général leroy un des
homosexuels de france et qui est l
autorité absolue sur tout ce qui se
passait en france ce qui est jeté à
monsieur qui s'appelait andré manu ce
qui était un homme très riche et très
longtemps
non mais j'ai dit non non j'ai dit fier
parce que tu annonces élèves c'est
vraiment il était un homme exquis
d'ailleurs donc monsieur manuce vous des
crêtes sex-symbol voilà il averti la
france entière qui a une bombe atomique
qui arrivent des cheats a alors j'ai eu
cocteau comme président du jury
j'ai vu philippe erlanger dans membres
du jury
oui alors qu'il y avait du monde
j'ai pas eu un prix que tout ça non pas
un prénom alors à ce moment là donc vous
donner aussi en france où l'on
s'intéresse énormément avoue et pas
seulement l'aristocratie homosexuels
comme vous dites mais fait la une de
signer monde et et vous refusez alors ça
c'est incroyable refuser un script un
claude chabrol
écoutez j'ai fait beaucoup de mauvais
films on m'a même énormément de mauvais
goût et mais je n'ai jamais voulu faire
un mauvais film en le sachant que j'ai
trouvé avec un grand metteur en scène
ça me semblait dans un tel gâchis alors
c'est à l'époque comme art que vous
rencontrez faten hamama qu'est la star
absolue à l'école de ma main non à ma
mère qui pour beaucoup est pas français
mais tant que guest star absolue c'est
maître capello qui est en moi la star
absolue donc du cinéma arabe mais qui
est marié oui ça fait un scandale ça
fait riche a fait scandale
et puis on est tombé amoureux quoi je
vais rien à faire avait rien à faire là
bas où j'avais 21 ans 1 et donc
elle a divorcé ouais et moi j'ai
embrassé l'islam
alors oui parce que il faut dire d'abord
c'est que c'est pas votre vrai nom
évidemment omar sharif votre vrai nom
c'est michel chalhoub et d'ailleurs
certains films où vous apparaissez sous
le nom de omar el sharif
c'est ça au début je m'appelle je
m'appelle omar el sharif comme on passe
pas un mais mais pour le pour les films
américains et marché français jean marc
cherry omar m'a tuer sur un générique
oui avec air et donc changé de nom et
vous convertir effectivement à la
religion musulmane
oui aujourd'hui que vous êtes dans quel
état d'esprit par rapport à ça moi je
suis en réalité je suis tolérant le che
hanno stick
ouais donc je ne crois pas mais j'ai le
doute je ne suis pas certain je n'ai
aucune certitude d'ailleurs non dans la
vie je suis prêt à douter de tout alors
votre premier film omar sur les écrans
occidentaux c'est la châtelaine du liban
et en 62 après laurence vous signez un
contrat de sept ans avec columbia et là
vous arrivez à hollywood à sa diète pour
vous signaler aux enseignants c'est bien
les avec les terriens parce que mais
vous avez j'arrive à hollywood en 62 1
donc j'arrive du caire à hollywood
directement 62 c'était la révolution
culturelle est là et c'était surtout la
révolution le mlf mouvement libération
de la femme
alors c'était en 62 qu'elles ont enlevé
tous les soutiens-gorge et qu' il ya eu
les discothèques
je suis arrivé en même temps que les
beatles et les rolling stones chaîne
tout cette décision
cette décennie exercice bien sûr c'est
celui connu est alors c'était pour moi
c'était arrivé à sodome et gomorrhe que
j'arrivais du caire
j'adore et comment les femmes que
j'avais jusque là en egypte où les
femmes étaient très très très couverte
ouailles arrière on ne ferait pas bon je
tenais à peine la main quand on avait
une petite amie mais alors là d'un coup
là tout le monde fait pratiquement à
quoi l'on joue c'est ça oui bof ils
étaient calmes et tout le monde sait en
effet les riches en egypte yao sinon il
ya un beau coup non mais je veux dire la
base c'était c'était plutôt la coquelles
et les drogues plus à l'époque c'était
la mode la haye d'accueil bien et alors
là vous sentez que vous allez craquer et
vous dit rien faten hamama votre femme
enfin madame sharif à l'époque
séparons nous avant que je te trompes
oui c'est extraordinaire ce nom ça veut
dire que je sentais la tentation rien
n'avait pas vu tout ça donc la première
fois et j'ai commencé à ressentir
vraiment une envie forte de tromper ma
femme
bon je suis vachement aux opticiens que
mon nom en plus alors chez nous donc à
l'époque on pensait que les femmes à
partir de 40 ans j'étais des vieilles
qui pourraient plus trouver un homme
ouais alors j'ai eu peur comme elle
avait deux enfants
elle allège pour une autre pour une
starlette quelconque et qu'elle n'est
plus l'opportunité de refaire sa vie
avec un homme
donc j'ai décidé qu'il valait mieux
c'est vachement de prévenir c'est pas
lâchement bien facile parce que de façon
vous l'auriez tromper vous le savez et
là vous dites plutôt que la garder avec
moi je la possibilité de refaire si elle
a refait sa vie faten hamama très bien
alors en cette chose qui ait eu raison
et cela dit moi je ne suis plus tombé
amoureux de personnes bah oui c'est ça
sert que vous dites depuis j'ai beaucoup
baiser d'un service à un ami
pas dit ça j'ai pas dit ça non vraiment
pas j'ai d'ailleurs pas beaucoup baiser
ça c'est jeune homme tu peux vous poser
beaucoup moins que tous mes copains
oui c'est ce que vous la main sud non
mais c'est vrai que c'est le nombre de
coups tirés mais c'est vrai vous dites
j'ai jamais aimé une autre femme et j'ai
jamais vécu avec une autre femme
même pas une semaine moi j'ai besoin
d'être amoureux pour vivre avec quatre
cas d'un navire à quelqu'un dont je ne
suis pas amoureux mais ce qu'il ya c'est
que moi je voyage est tout le temps je
suis le seul acteur au monde qui n'est
pas qui suis étranger partout 1
donc j'avais ma valise j'allais dans des
hôtels et si une femme avait voulu me
suivre et vivre avec moi je ne l'aurais
pas aimer parce que j'aurais été une
femme qui ne travaillait pas à casa rien
sauf de s'occuper de moi je n'aime pas
les femmes servent ils viennent plutôt
me back de disputer avec quelques
briques par des arguments des arguments
mais c'est vrai qu'on vous prête des
aventures avec les plus belles femmes du
monde
non mais c'est parce que j'étais
célibataire et que on pouvait dire quand
tu vois que je sortais avec quelqu'un
pouvait dire les chanteurs forme voilà
puisqu'il est libre
on dit que les hommes mariés c'est plus
délicat on les voit avec quelqu'un
d'autre on ne mange pas vraiment écrire
dans le journal que ils ont une aventure
alors je dis les plus belles femmes du
monde
il ya barbra streisand c'est pas la plus
belle femme du monde d'ailleurs la
première fois que vous l'avez vu vous ce
que vous appelez votre agent devant je
n'ai pas tourné avec elle et romeu des
scènes d'amour ne vivent pas tourner des
scènes je veux pas lui dire tu m as roma
aurait alors anita ekberg c'est vrai ça
quand même non écoutez il ya une
condition que j'ai posées pour être avec
une femme
j'ai besoin de ne pas me mettre sur la
pointe des pieds pour l'embrasser et
j'ai besoin de pouvoir que mes mèches
jouanny derrière son dos c'était un peu
il s'est apprécié de faire comme c'est
pas possible
allez la dotera je vais pas partie de la
liste l'enfant disons yanouk aimé oui
oui j'ai une amitié amoureuse
voilà j'ai eu d amitié amour est qu'il
evelyne dhéliat libyen qui la pêche ou
par non sophie davant
non non je balance par aucun bail tu es
donc vous avez déclaré effectivement
quand j'ai quitté l'egypte pour faire ma
carrière internationale j'avais un bel
appartement une belle femme
un gosse que j'adorais et depuis j'ai
vécu seul d'hôtel en hôtel avec une
valise quand même ça va inviter dans
l'hôtel l'hiver est au sheraton du caire
c'est ça en général ça va juin septembre
royal monceau à paris
voilà c'est pas le camping non mais
alors c'est très marrant d'ailleurs
parce que au royal monceau
vous ouvrez jamais les rideaux ou sais
même pas si la fenêtre sur la rue si on
a un goût sûr la cour parce que vous
dites j'ai vu tout c'est terrible ça
j'ai vu tous les paysages et la seule
chose dont j'ai besoin maintenant ce
sont des visages oui c'est vrai j'aime
j'aime les gens j'aime j'aime quand je
vais dans un pays que je ne connais pas
j'aime connaître les gens et les ti vous
êtes à deauville au royal barrière au
royal ça va quand même très bien 1 bah
oui c'est super mais le luxe est pas
tout moi je veux dire les grands hôtels
tout ça n'est pas tout il faut du coup
ce soir un endroit
vous n'êtes pas de mots c'est pas de
maison d'un foyer j'ai pas d'objets par
exemple et aucun objet c'est marrant
j'ai pas par exemple je peux pas
transporter mes livres d'hôtel en hôtel
n'est pas de livre j'ai pas de disque
excusez moi un petit peu comme un
travailleur et oui anoman alors c'était
une maison 3 pas quand même
vous êtes devenu disons joueurs par
ennui justement par misanthropie vous
dites pour occuper le temps en fait
c'est à dire que vous êtes seul le soir
dans une chambre d'hôtel
ben vous préférez aller dans un casino
paris le 10 juin femmes on peut dîner
seul c'est le seul endroit on n'est pas
ridicule quand on va seulement on avait
aussi on est un acteur on va dans un
restaurant tout seul et vont commander
un repas on est ridicule on se sent
ridicule comme ça dit qu'un casino on
peut aller tout seul le gîte avis
solitaire effectué mes chaînes mais je
ne suis pas passionné par le jeu je peux
m'en passer
si j'ai un rendez-vous à dîner ou si
j'ai une petite amie par exemple par
hasard eh bien je ne pense pas du tout
aller jouer tout le monde croit que vous
êtes accro au jeu ne sera pas du tout
gênée je n'aime pas sa pratique
c'est le dernier j'ai la dernière chose
qui me reste un an je n'ai rien de mieux
à faire
le plus grosses pertes c'est en 78 ou
palm beach 80 millions de francs d'une
soirée non j'ai perdu j'ai perdu beau
des grosses sommes mais j'ai une fois
j'ai gagné et plusieurs fois j'ai perdu
mais moi j'ai la sortie s'en sortir plus
gagner plus perdu c'est ça qui apprend
beaucoup plus perdu jusque là perdu
troublant de l'argent je gagne je le
perds oui mais parce que j'ai une
particularité c'est que quand j'ai de
l'argent je suis obligé de le dépenser
j'ai vraiment je n'arrive pas à garder
l'argent les poches percées commander
mais ça ne me gêne pas de ne pas en
avoir plein d'autres je vis aussi
heureusement quand je n'en ai pas je
change de restaurant je vais dans toute
la bande lors des brasseries faut juste
payer l'hôtel avant je paie pas l'hôtel
je ne vais pas je ne fais pas d'hôtel
c'est pour ça que je peux me permettre
non mais sinon vous pourriez vous auriez
cru que j'étais riche si je vivais au
royal monceau ap hm c'est bêtement que
c'était payant
lens je suis l'invité un propriétaire la
royal monceau est un monsieur très très
bien que si rien qui m'aiment bien
d'accord j'ai moi aussi beaucoup la
syrie démocratique où les gens sont très
heureux non mais un soir j'ai perdu une
fois ci c'est vrai mais au casino
l'appartement que vous possédiez à paris
c'est vrai ça veut dire j'ai dû vendre
mon appart ans pour payer mes dettes de
jeux et autres là d'accord j'avais c'est
la seule fois où j'ai eu un appartement
un essai ça va durer finale mais voilà
ça a duré quatre cinq ans mais quand
même très bien alors vous appelez votre
argent le lendemain matin il on trouve
moi un film n'importe quelle merde ce
que tu veux demain mais le focus à
demain demain voilà fallait que ça
demain j'avais toujours un film de
retard d'ailleurs que j'ai chaque film
qui tourne et c'était pour payer les
dettes de l avait déjà un peu comme
darricau là il ya des gens et des genres
lefebvre jean louis vous êtes obligés de
faire de la pub pour tiercé magazine
oui je le fais encore ouais je vous ai
vu notre journée c'est bien parce que
c'est ça me fais moi j'ai toujours eu
envie d'avoir un salaire en avant une
rentrée nette plus que chaque mois alors
parce que le problème de l'acteur c'est
que chaque fois qu'on tourne un film on
sait pas quand est ce qu'on va tourner
un autre alors que le fait d'avoir une
rentrée sur ça me rassure ouais ça mais
ça me fait plaisir et ça fait beaucoup
de gens alors dites moi il s'est passé
quoi au casino d'enghien le 5 juillet là
j'ai mis un coup de boule à un policier
oui oui oui exactement belge qui s'est
passé c'est que brand
je perdais pas mal et puis un soir bon
j'étais seul à la table où je jouais là
à la roulette mais j'ai insulté le
croupier lorsqu'il avait fait ou pas une
connerie je ne me souviens pas
clairement de la soirée mes souvenirs ne
correspond pas aux films qu'ils ont
tourné de ce qui s'est passé n'est qu'un
petit film et quand ils ont montré qu on
est encore jeune et qu'il aurait
finalement vous traitez j'ai raconté
quand on quand on m'a mis en garde à vue
a raconté à la police qui s'était passé
mais après ils ont vu que ce n'était pas
comme ça du tout alors je qui s'est
passé en réalité ce qui est filmé c'est
que je n'ai insultés très gravement
enfin avec des mots très violents et que
donc ils ont appelé le commissaire de la
police des jeux qui est venu pour
m'éjecter alors pour me dire monsieur
quitté le casino nom et le il est venu
avec les deux ou trois leaders avec lui
du casino qui étaient des malabars lui
aussi d'ailleurs cela malabat et ému m
entouré pour me faire sortir
et moi j'ai une agoraphobie j'ai peur
des foules
enfin je ne fis j'aime pas me sentir
contraints par une foule alors et le
film montre ça je dis ne me touchez pas
ne me touchez pas et personne ne me
toucher ouais mais il était tout autour
de moi et alors en me retournant comme
ça j'étais une espèce le genre je me
débattais coin dans ma tête et je me
retourne comme ça et je vois c'était
malheureusement c'était pas un des
videurs c'était le commissaire de police
lui même qui est aveugle à lui donner un
petit coup de boule et bill
vient enfin bon on est là et il n'a pas
eu et je crois qu'il a eu un jour
d'arrêt de travail parce que il est venu
témoigner parce qu'il est venue le
lendemain on a passé la journée à
témoigner elle a souvent quand on a les
jetons mets un coup de boule sans
réflexe
le châtelet
alors omar sharif le retour au cinéma
donc avec votre film montré à venise et
qui sort en france le 17 septembre et
qui s'appelle monsieur ibrahim et les
fleurs du coran de françois dupeyron
dans l'histoire mais c'est l'histoire
d'un petit garçon justement il s'appelle
mme oumou mais ça ne tient pas pour moi
rappelle maurice voilà en fait ils
s'appellent molise
il habite seul avec son père qui est
jouée par an dans un travail à part te
mangerais oui c'est ça dans un très
vieil appartement et son père c'est
gilbert melki qui est excellent qui vont
très très bon acteur sa mère n'est plus
là et les seuls bons moments qu'il a ce
petit garçon ce petit momo c'est quand
il arrive à économiser 35 francs pour
aller se taper une [ __ ] parce que c'est
un quartier quand même pas mal de buts
faut bien le dire apprendre saint front
à 35 ans mais ça n'est pas que ça se
passe il ya se passe dans les années 60
c'est ce passé des pommiers salut les
copains et d'ailleurs toute la musique
c'est la bande-son de salut les copains
1 et il avait déjà fait sa marmite là
donc il a eut prouvé qu'ils pouvaient
voilà alors quand il va pas se taper des
[ __ ] le petit mot il va faire ses
courses chez l'arabe comme on dit
monsieur ibrahim est en fait vous on
vous appellera bout dit à un moment
parce que l'épicerie est ouverte de
glace journée même le 10 mars voilà
mais en fait vous n'êtes pas arabe vous
êtes turc mais vous êtes musulman
oui je suis soufi musulmans voilà et
puis en fait cet enfant vient dans la
vie de cet homme qui avait probablement
envie d'avoir un gosse d'avoir un enfant
d'un alloués pour jouer avec lui comme
comme un enfant lui aussi c'est un
personnage qui est un peu mystérieux
parce qu'en fait ce personnage n'existe
que quand l'enfant est là on le voit
jamais 100 ans mais bon c'est vrai alors
ça peut-être pourrait imaginer n'importe
quoi mais je veux dire on pourrait
imaginer qu'il n'existe pas que quand
l'enfant est là l'enfant l'imaginent oui
moi je vous dis un truc qu'il ya quelque
chose dans ce film qui m'a complètement
scotché c'est que le petit garçon dont
qu'il vient faire ses courses et
chaparder un petit peu dans votre
épicerie et puis un moment il toujours
un peu triste comme ça alors vous avez
cette phrase magnifique du sourire non
voilà cette fois c'est d'aimer
faussurier des je ne souris pas passer
par juin c'est quand on sourit qu'on le
devient
or c'était magnifique c'est le sourire
[Musique]
je suis à toi
ok je me foute en inde n'était pas un
arabe se réparer je ne suis pas avoir
mon moi je viens du croissant d'or
commentaire du vacherin si vous êtes
parra tape à racheter sa part à mme ben
amor ça veut dire ouverts de 8 heures du
matin jusqu'à minuit elle même le
dimanche dans l'épicerie hier tablier
d'accueil la douche
moana sait comment faites vous pour
retrouver ses sourires qui rend attentif
pour ça je crois de terminale es t
supérieure
ça te dirait une petite balade le
dimanche après midi
[Musique]
ici j'ai la police ou pas le voir vous
connaissez le père il vaut mieux qu'on
parlait en chambre je comprends pas ne
pas tout comprendre avec la tête quand
ses volants noté l'institut
[Musique]
gaston
sonic youth
j'ai moi toute ma vie j'aurai beaucoup
travaillé mais en prenant mon temps
lentement la langue c'est ça les
chiffres ibrahim et les fleurs du coran
de françois dupeyron avec omar sharif et
pierre boulanger d'après eric emmanuel
schmitt et la bande son est vachement
bien
prévention et magnifique bien ça c'est
beau la musique des années 60 à sévère
voilà vous avez pu faire de cinéma un
juste avant là ce nom je voulais plus
faire je voulais plus faire justement je
voulais arrêter ce cycle infernal des
films mauvais que je veux tourner et
j'avais décidé donc de terminer comme ça
un peu plus dignement que si j'avais
continué si ce scénario est arrivé et ça
m'a emballé que j'ai voulu faire mon
problème c'est un problème de casting
ce qui est assez que quand on est jeune
et qu'on est une star on vous écrit
dérouleront à la date des rôles on
voulait change pour que ça aille pour
vous mais quand on devient vieux et
qu'on vend plus des fauteuils mettons
alors là il faut trouver des vins qui
vous convient qu'ils aillent pour vous
parce qu' on a besoin d'un vieux
français on prend un vieil acteur
français sur un besoin d'avis ça tombait
bien là haut
alors je revendique que quand on a
besoin d'un vieil arabe il faut
m'appeler alors vous avez eue dans votre
vie des hauts et des bas comme tout le
monde et on va faire une interview à
peine d'armes
[Musique]
sharif ce que vous préférez en vous ma
ma chance la chance que j'ai ouais c'est
pas en moi c'est fini sur une bonne
chose une bonne étoile et une chance
folle toute ma vie vous voyez pas été
plus heureux si vous aviez vécu au caire
finalement avec faten hamama mais on est
dans une star cairote on les sent une
star égyptienne c'est possible je ne le
saurai jamais je ne ferai jamais ce qui
serait arrivé si on m'avait pas pris
pour lawrence d'arabie
il est fort possible que j'aurais été
plus heureux dans ma vie oui parce que
vous soyez aussi peut-être pas comme ça
dans une chambre d'hôte heures il dit
gorges l'uréthane par un trial famille
patrie alors ça ce que vous haïssez en
vous je n'ai rien en moi parce que quand
je fais quelque chose je l'aï c'est
quelque chose en moins je ferai de tous
pour corriger cette chose que j'ai
d'ailleurs beaucoup de fric à c'était en
66 fric
j'ai gagné un million $ au casino
lorsque j'étais avec une gt dans le nord
de l'italie
il y avait une starlette qui était assis
à côté de moi qui étais très très bien
et on est allé à discothèque on a flirté
tout puis j'ai dit de monter avec moi
chez elle voulait bien prendre un verre
dans ma chambre m'a dit non j'étais fou
de rage et j'avais bu pas mal et je suis
allé au casino et j'ai joué le numéro
que je ne joue jamais c'est à dire le 29
à la roulette et ses sorties 4 x 2 from
effet réalisé la banque ouais alors le
lendemain j'ai acheté toutes les fleurs
d'interflora 1 et j'ai envoyé un camion
parce que tu es allé à rome
j'en veux un camion de fleurs à cette
jeune dame qui était dans north tout à
fait 2,5 tonnes 5 tonnes de fleurs crise
cardiaque
elle est devenu florissant du retour et
puis jérémy brésil et inélégamment une
carte qui disait vous auriez été le coup
le plus cher de ma vie le plus grosses
pertes c'est quand vous a été obligé de
vendre ou de votre appartement
oui j'ai oui j'ai aussi c'était dans cet
ordre là autant ces sommes là et c'était
tout l'argent que je possédais au monde
à ce moment là la sorbonne en banque
le plus grand moment de votre vie
difficile le plus grand moment j'ai
peut-être fait pas la naissance de mon
fils vient probablement j'adore mon fils
je suis vraiment en fanatique de mon
fils et j'ai la mienne aussi
et le pire moment le plus je ne sais pas
c'est là c'est tous les moments de
déchéance physique quand quand on est
malade et que les nerfs doivent
s'occuper de vous et vous accompagne et
à la salle de bain ça c'est des moments
atroces
j'étais malade touché j'ai eu et j'ai
fait un pontage et eu à une hanche et
changé une hanche c'est une prothèse
j'ai une prothèse
vous suivez plus là non je suis même pas
à manger à rester au top il faut saluer
un miracle pour arrêter de fumer parce
que je fumais 100 cigarettes par jour et
un jour j'ai eu mal à la poitrine et
j'ai compris que cette écriture de
cardiaque
alors comme je ne savais pas qui parle
et j'ai regardé le plafond et je lui ai
parlé
gd coûte je n'ai jamais parlé avant je
te dire maintenant si tu me fais vivre
jusqu'à demain matin j'arrête de fumer
bon et puis j'ai arrêté puis j'ai repris
une cigarette allumée j'ai eu un choc
électrique extremis dans ma bouche
j'ai été très malade j'ai vomi j'ai eu
des nausées terrible et depuis je n'ai
plus pu toucher une cigarette
vous avez alors cahiers et je lui ai
plus jamais parler j'attends
m
et quand c'est l'émission hebdo du vieux
plus belle histoire d'amour c'est faten
hamama j'imagine oui sûrement un surnom
c'est ma seule et puis tous les autres
qui font remarquer sophie davant evelyne
dhéliat marie ange nardi wii est la plus
minable
marie-ange nardi vous savez qu'elle met
elle même
en vo
quand elle était à la pyramide qu'elle
faisait la meilleure amie de la soeur
des pyramides
il ya une question sur moi hein donc on
a dix qui est à jouer docteur je vois un
truc comme ça
elle a pas su répondre quelque et après
on l'a dit mais c'est omar sharif bien
sûr elle a dit mais j'ai jamais entendu
parler aulas alors tu vois je chéris
scénario envisagé une aventure avec elle
qui a très bien marché c'est pas comme
sophie davant bien alors votre vote vous
le plus minable histoire d'amour tiens
on vient me faisait me lave l'histoire
d'un monde ça a été avec rita hayworth
non oui c'était j'ai eu une aventure
pigments stupéfiante avec un peu je
l'admirais beaucoup depuis que j'étais
très jeune et un soir elle était elle
avait assez bu et je les raccompagner
chez elle habitait sur les eaux de
cannes ont fait tourner un film ensemble
et moi j'habitais à nice et quand on est
arrivé il m'a dit ce que vous voulez
prendre un verre
je descends en avait une voiture de la
production avec un chauffeur je vais
avec elle elle avait un bar qui était en
belle manif vous aimez le vin blanc j'ai
compris que c'est ce qu'elle voulait que
je boive j'ai pris un verre de vin blanc
de r et puis on a flirté en la flore tu
es très bientôt
et puis au moment où on était au point
de au point culminant de notre relation
elle me dit mais vous croyez que vous
allez me sauter vous je suis car n'ont
jamais patrick flores qui un jour a mass
media sabic qui était partout jours
qu'ils ont créé un jeté mes copains elle
me dit allez sortez vous êtes vous
croyez que vous êtes arrivé vous avez
tourné un film mais van holland d'arabie
je vous avais laissé jusqu'à oui mais
elle était sous la peau informatique
bref elle me dit sortez alain je sors et
a pas la voiture
alors je dis mais où est la voiture est
munie de renvoyer marché et jeu et j'ai
fait de l'auto-stop à 5 heures du matin
qui buvait du thé à la main
[Rires]
non pas parce que on va garder à la cuve
est aussi un oui mais elle était
adorable s'était même brême mais
vraiment ma copine si vous préférez dans
le sexe les préliminaires
mais voilà c'était le cas je serais
content que le mais virer avant impôt
retraité ce qui vous dégoûte le plus
dans le sexe le l'après sexe quand ça se
passe mal
1 quand on se retourne chacun de son
côté contador ou un staff ou qu'on doive
se rhabiller de partir pas de bagnole
l'ordre est maintenant
voici frédéric beigbeder
[Musique]
ce krach j'ai dit des bee gees c'était à
la fois pour le sujet de votre livre est
à la fois pour ce qui s'est passé là la
semaine dernière oui alors la semaine
dernière qu est ce qui s'est passé je me
souviens de rien l'oim
merci c'est incroyable je dois de la
vodka à dire que ici on vous sert
énormément de votre cas tony une fille
très charmant très joli le pen même rica
voilà qui laisse aller très bien passé
son temps à venir me voir est ce que
vous voulez encore un verre josé oui et
c'est tout ça se passe est une manière
sympathique jusqu'au moment où je me
suis dit que j'étais trop éméchés pour
parler d'un livre qui est important pour
moi
malgré l'important est qu'il est un
livre c'est grave et voilà mais mais
c'est bien dans la rue effectivement là
tous les gens pendant une semaine m'ont
jamais demandé comment j'allais si je
connaissais la belgique miloci ball dit
donc c'est très finalement c'est une
belle aventure avec votre maman vous lui
avez dit je fais faire dix ont regardé
quand elle vous a vu tomber dans la loge
ouais c'est ben oui non j'aimerais dire
aux gens qui nous regardent ne faites
pas ça chez vous c'est mal une fois
féerique vous souvenez ça c'était il ya
un an
mon employeur furtif frédéric omar a
fait une émission sur canal + qui
s'appelait l'hyper show qui a été une
catastrophe
un an après le garçon qui l'a remplacé
fait pareil avec trois fois plus
d'argent donc finalement on se dit que
c'est la casque est maudite frédéric ça
vous dédouane d'une certaine façon je
trouve que c'était peut-être pas si
catastrophique que ça me fait un nom
maintenant effectivement est alors un an
après vous êtes au sommet votre livre
est l'événement littéraire de la rentrée
vous avez décidé en plus tellement ça
marche de faire deux télés tout le monde
en parle et cnn qu est ce qu est plus
chic tout le monde un être omar sharif
et puis le figaro magazine vous appelle
le nouveau bhl avant c'était françois
nourrisson ouais mais c'est vrai
maintenant c'est le nouveau bh ça me
fait beaucoup de choses hein même si
vous n'avez pas fait de télé depuis
quelques temps vous êtes toujours
critique littéraire quand même un aux
journaleux voici toujours dj dans des
soirées j'espère et vous êtes devenu
éditeur frédéric entre temps directeur
littéraire chez flammarion vous dit
frédéric éditeurs finalement s'est
attaché de presse de luxe ça peut être
aussi quand n'importe quelle boîte de
nuit vous dit toi oui toi non un toit
revient dans six mois
possible toi tu as un oui mais toi non
c'est un peu comme ça alors c'est
l'écrivain que nous recevons ce soir
après l'amour dure trois ans 99 francs
qui a été traduit en vingt langues et
qui sera bientôt adapté au cinéma par
antoine de caunes avec edouard baer 1 et
encore un cas intérêt à pas faire trop
de télé non plus edouard baer 1 et
aujourd'hui vous publiez donc chez
grasset frédéric un bouquin qui
s'appelle windows on the world bonsoir
par locale au clair que c'est une soirée
dtc excuse moi c'est nous
ces nouveaux jeux dati a loupé le
l'alchimie saloperie la merci beaucoup
d'envolées windows à doha
alors les critiques professionnels
disent que c'est votre meilleur roman je
le pense aussi bien que n'étant pas
crédit professionnel
en tous les cas c'est l'événement
littéraire de la rentrée c'est le cas de
le dire tout le monde en parle il ya eu
j'ai fait le compte
autant de mots écrits sur votre livre
depuis qu'il est sorti qu'il y en a dans
votre livre
voilà c'est un peu françois nourissier a
dit en parlant de se vivre comme quoi on
peut avoir du succès et du talent alors
là dans ces cas là il faut au chai la
tête un aliment ouais qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire dans ces cas là n est pas
trop de fausse modestie mais en même
temps c'est vrai que vrai que je trouve
peut-être c'est excessif
ouais en même temps je me dis je me dis
souvent il ya des gens qui ont du succès
qu'ils sont nuls à chier au sein donc
c'est ça le risque fofana que les
critiques sont d'accord pour dire que
c'est vachement bien qu'est ce que c'est
les nouviale
les médias
suprême mémoire
tout le monde peut jouer à la maison
venus et serena
les soeurs williams merci
on va se parler ni de soleil
en même temps c'est pas un casting qui
était fait avant il faut dire que si le
marché du jour bien alors si on voulait
résumer ce livre en deux mots moi je
dirais avions destruction puisque ça
parle de l'attentât du 11 septembre et
autour destruction puisque vous parlez
de vous et d'une façon assez masochiste
parfois je trouve alors un coup c'est
mieux parce que c'est bizarre alors
danser dans ce roman catastrophe qui est
la première dimension du lit vous allez
au delà des images puisque évidemment
nous on a vu ça de l'extérieur
et vous imaginez comment ça s'est passé
pour ceux qui étaient bloqués entre le
point d'impact des avions de l'avion en
est
et puis le toit finalement parce que
cela il était vous dites comme dans une
espèce de chambres à gaz cesser
évidemment un huit clos terrifiant et on
n'a pas de témoignages très peu on a
très très peu de on n'a aucune
photographie aucune image et c'est ce
black out
cette censure tout à fait légitime de la
presse américaine que j'essaie de braver
disons avec la fiction avec
l'imagination
je me dis que le roman a peut-être cette
utilité là ne pouvoir entrer dans des
lieux interdits
oui parce que tu es incroyable c'est que
l'on a publié les appels qui ont été
passées sur des boîtes vocales par les
gens qui sont mort l'a finalement c'est
pas très loin de ce que vous racontez
dans le bouquin et c'est publié après la
sortie et ses traits ce qui est très
curieux en fait c'est de s'apercevoir
que effectivement à partir d'une
documentation finalement assez limité
suite à cette censure eh bien on arrive
à trouver la vérité quoi comme comme on
parle beaucoup de cocteau en ce moment
qui disait je suis un mensonge qui dit
toujours la vérité
peut-être que le roman c'est la même
chose alors on visse cette catastrophe
de l'intérieur donc à travers un père
qui est venu là un père d'une
quarantaine d'années agent immobilier
qui a mené ses deux enfants windows
pour info un breakfast alors c'est très
fort votre truc parce que vous utilisez
le procédé de béni dans la vie est belle
c'est à dire que effectivement vous le
dit d'ailleurs vous dites je vais voilà
c'est un peu comme bénigne sauf que
c'est comme un magicien qui fait un tour
il explique tu doives j'ai compris et
quand il refait mon marche encore
batterie d'eric c'est pareil avec son
bouquin sur qui nous dit je vais vous
faire un coup à la benini effectivement
le père fait croire à ses enfants que
c'est un jeu un parc d'attractions
huawei ailleurs explique le restaurant
il bouge c'est normal il ya des rivets
hydraulique la fumée que vous voyez
c'est des fumigènes les figurants qui
crisse et des gens payés ils essaient de
l'est de l'est
2les enfin de calmer leur peur comme ça
à travers le jeu et puis ensuite ça se
retourne on rentre dans la tête des
enfants et ce sont les enfants qui
imaginent que leur père c'est clark kent
il va se transformer en super héros oui
toujours pas parmi les super pouvoirs
c'est extrêmement poignant mais s'est
basé sur une histoire vraie basé sur des
faits réels et existe sous story alors
ça c'est ce que j'appelle avions
destruction donc c'est la première
dimension du livre et l'autre moitié
c'est l'auto destruction car ce livre où
l'écrivain frédéric beigbeder au sommet
de la tour montparnasse où vous allez
prendre des petits déjeuners avec avec
votre fille pas aussi de vous remettre
dans la même situation d'une certaine
façon j'ai toujours parlé que de mon
nombril et c'est très compliqué quand on
a aucune imagination de se lancer dans
un roman purement fictif et donc je suis
allé dans un restaurant il ya assez peu
de restaurants au monde qui sont en
hausse au dernier étage d'une tour il
sauf qu'il y en a à paris la tour
montparnasse et donc j'étais
j'étais là en train de prendre des notes
et d'essayer de d'imaginer les odeurs
les couleurs les bruits mais ces voies
la c1 c'était un moyen pour moi de faire
ce travail de tarbes à côté d'un côté il
ya le côté de best-sellers roman
catastrophe à l'américaine et de l'autre
côté
ses dimensions le roman en train de
s'écrire le making-of le work and
process et on voit frédéric écrit son
bouquin avec sa fille ça c'est très
littéraire c'est très européen ça
rajoute la dimension européenne au
bouquin est alors dans votre volonté
comme ça de faire un roman total ya
aussi des photos dans votre livre il ya
deux photos il ya un moment où si vous
voulez les la typographie prend la forme
d des tours du world trade center enfin
t'as vu le manque d'alcool ce que ça
donne
ouais vous êtes comme une sorte de
funambule comme ça qu'ils marchaient
entre le wall trade center et la tour
montparnasse fait des allers retours
c'est ça ce bouquin c'est très curieux
c'est très curieux parce que bon il ya
trois endroits il la tour montparnasse
le world trade center et concorde et il
ya deux des trois endroits qui déjà
n'existe plus alors la tour montparnasse
écoutez c'est dommage que la tour
montparnasse existe encore d'ailleurs
vous dit que quand on est au sommet de
la tour montparnasse c'est génial parce
que c'est le seul endroit d'où on la
voit pas voilà l'époque dans tous les
cas la marque alors dans ce making of
parallèle de l'histoire donc du wall
trade center finalement vous faites une
espèce d'examen de conscience de bilan
par rapport à cette autre quarantenaire
qui lui est mort là-bas et et finalement
vous réfléchissez comme lui comme votre
héros à la paternité joui je crois le
derrière les deux tours le sujet du
lycée ça c'est ce que ça m'a fait quand
j'ai vu cette tragédie d'avoir donné la
vie et toute cette culpabilité mon
irresponsabilité aussi de jeunes perd un
peu un convaincant et puis voilà cette
magnifique catastrophe
et
et même un petit peu amené à me poser
des questions tout simplement sur les
années soixante dix années de mon
enfance qui sont attaqués elle aussi
puisque c'est la date où on a construit
le world trade center
donc tout ça s'entremêlent un petit peu
j'espère de manière oui funambulesque
sans tomber trop non ça va et
culpabilité aussi du père qui a
abandonné la mère et l'enfant
oui c'est il me semble que l'absence du
père est à une réalité nouvelle
un que depuis les années 60 la
libération sexuelle qui est une très
bonne nouvelle
oui voilà 60 de hollywood tout ça j'ai
suivi un mais c'est vrai que ça c'est
très positif c'est aussi ça qui est
attaquée aujourd'hui parlent par les
fanatiques islamistes c'est ça qui est
menacée et en même temps ça aussi des
aspects négatifs
c'est vrai que c'est de plus en plus
difficile de construire une famille
aujourd'hui quand on est un garçon un
petit peu écervelée comme moi là-dedans
seul coup vous rigolez plus que d'un
seul coup le cynique est en larmes là
c'est par rapport à mon roman précédent
effectivement sur un livre plus plus
grave plus plombant je remarque
d'ailleurs que la plomber l'ambiance
message prévient les gens chez eux sont
morts de rien c'est pas plombé par tous
et oui je peut-être j'avais envie après
avoir si jamais j'ai fait rigoler au
précédent peut-être essayer la 2de de
jouer plus sur les émotions
céline disait que de la littérature ça
servait uniquement à ça un mois j'ai
marché
omar sharif
j'écoutais tout ça vous allez lire le
livre de frédéric voir je vais vraiment
mais vous compte ya eu le 11 septembre
j'ai réagi comme ans j'ai eu la peur de
shekels et non seulement ce qui était
arrivé est ce que je voyais j'ai aussi
vu la peur des conséquences sur le
peuple arabe sur le peuple islamique le
peuple musulman bras était c'est à dire
que effectivement maintenance et c'est
beaucoup plus difficile pour les pour
nous les arabes je veux dire le monde
est devenu un endroit beaucoup plus
difficile plutôt impliqué pour un on est
regardé avec méfiance la pub le tout le
temps période là j'étais en train de
remplir ma mort formulaire pour prendre
mon visa pour aller en angleterre et
j'ai vu alors qu'il y avait des
questions et vous jamais participé à un
acte terroriste n'ont jamais vérifié en
jeu décès il ya des choses qui sont qui
ont changé d'une façon terrible afin de
le regard du monde sur le monde arabe et
sur le monde islamique a changé
complètement ça c'est vrai ça c'est
peut-être aussi dû à la simplification
audiovisuel c'est pas pour critiquer mon
ex métier mais c'est vrai que la télé
fait que les gens sont assimilés à leurs
dirigeants c'est à dire que par exemple
on va détester les américains à cause de
georges bush où on va détester les
arabes à cause de ben laden ou détester
les français à cause de dominique de
villepin
et ça je crois que c'est c'est nouveau
ça n'a pas toujours été comme ça on sait
très bien qu en démocratie
énormément de gens ne sont pas d'accord
avec leurs dirigeants
alors frédéric beigbeder donc le bouquin
s'appelle windows on the world c'est
chez grasset vous n'êtes toujours pas
numéro 11 est toujours numéro de nom oui
je suis le poulidor de la rencontre
étant quand même fait d'elle je
comprends pas non c'est normal parce que
devant moi j'ai eddy merckx une
romancière belge amélie nothomb avec
antekrist h chez albin michel
j'imagine d'ailleurs qu'après cette
émission vous allez devenir numéro 1
sciences est pas possible frédéric mais
je compte un peu sur vous un
vous avoir un prix non j'ai vu vous
étiez sur la liste du renaudot et du
goncourt et alcoolique brieuc prix du
vomi ouais
non non c'est vrai que j'ai pensé à ça
c'est que je voudrais préciser que je
n'ai absolument pas vomi 1 puis une
semaine aussi les gens me disaient c'est
dégueulasse et c est en fait le vomi
c'est vachement glamour quand c'est sur
mtv jackass mais quand c'est moi c'est
juste minable donc tout va bien qu'on
arrête d'en parler
ouais vous êtes toutes les chances
d'avoir le bon cours alors là j'en sais
rien non vous savez c'est le centenaire
du prix goncourt et m'ont donné un
centenaire
non mais mon mon roman un titre en
anglais 1 et je trouve que pour le
centième anniversaire du prix goncourt
je sais maintenant ce n'est pas sain ni
s'ils auront envie de le donner un titre
en anglais
fédérer quand il a créé chez nous vous
êtes récompensé ce soir la carte de bons
clients mieux
y'a pas mieux si il ya le panthéon frais
d avec le hall of fame non annoncé omar
sharif annoncez-vous frédéric non
marcheurs et villages et le désastre car
lui c'est vous ferez des mails
m
là
[Applaudissements]
mais les entrées dans le panthéon
à côté de pierre palmade voilà alors
fédérer officiellement la carte de bons
clients à omar ben oui bien sûr alors
consolation ce que signifie la carte
devant le client m'a tu es chez toi tu
viens quand tu veux c'est comme un cloud
allez vous venez quand vous les siens
sausset les pins les arabes et dans
toutes les banques tu peux tirer un
million de dollars si des foyers des
problèmes au casino fédérer vous savez
que le hall of fame c'est pas toutes les
semaines ça fait deux semaines de suite
mais la semaine prochaine aura peut-être
personne qui est terrible c'est que là
vous m'avez vraiment foutu en l'air le
prix goncourt baisse et maintenant ils
vont dire il a eu le hall of fame
d'ardisson il a besoin du grand four
et
alors nous devions accueillir à ce
moment de l'émission andré glucksmann
mais nous avons été prévenus en fin
d'après midi qu'il était victime d'un
malaise et qu'il a été hospitalisé
j'espère que c'est pas trop grave
andré en tous les cas on pense à toi
c'est le syndrome beigbeder bah je sais
pas mais en tous les cas rien du cas
excéder c'est peut-être le vert voilà
peut-être adecco toute verte
je sais pas en tout les cas glucksmann
est à l'hosto et nous avons donc décidé
d'avancer d'une semaine
marc edouard nabe
[Musique]
alors quoi
comment ça va très bien vous connaissez
oui oui oui bien présent ce cas merci
d'être venu comme ça au débotté au
débotté marc-edouard merci beaucoup
embrasé bah oui mais bon à tous pour
point à brûle pourpoint oui j'ai tous
les maux alors qu'en beigbeder dit nous
sommes tous américains vous vous dites
nous sommes tous irakien ah oui bien sûr
allez frédéric tu peux tu peux me dire à
moi c'est un gag ton livre tu peux pas
sérieusement avoir fait ça sincèrement
aux six mois pour moi le latium n'excuse
ce serait le serait le cynisme si tu
veux si tu étais cynique et que tu que
tu ai fait ça dans une volonté de
publicité d'ailleurs très très louable
pour faire quelque chose pendant le 11
septembre
je comprendrais mais là plusieurs fois
je t'écoute et tu as tu as une 1ère de
gravité tu as l'air de vraiment de 2,2
de croire en ce que tu dis je trouve ça
grave
pourquoi part parce que la situation
n'est pas halal à la plaisanterie avec
ce genre de sujet c'est fait vous lui
reprocher d'être mais oui mais on le
fait il le fait il s'est pas de cette
gravité là si on ne peut pas tu peux pas
mais l'état superficialité aux gravats
du wall trade center
tu vois et je te le dis parce que il ya
beaucoup de copains et moi je ne suis
pas un copain je suis un ami et un ami
c'est quelqu'un qui doit te dire la
vérité enfin en tout cas sa vérité et je
ne veux moi j'ai pas je ne fais pas
partie de ces types qui te tresse des
louanges des loges par intérêt ou par
complaisance ou ou pour différents
métiers moi j'aime beaucoup le livre de
frédéric bien sûr mais il ya quelque
chose qui m'a chi chi chi dont on ne
peut absolument pas
enfin qu'on peut pas passer sous silence
c'est cette apologie de l'amérique que
tu fais aujourd'hui elle est extrêmement
déplacé deux ans après après ce qui
s'est passé le 11 septembre 2001 il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup d'événements qui se
sont produits depuis deux ans étienne tu
n'as pas l'air d'en tenir compte en fait
ce que tu dis c'est que nous sommes tous
américains c'est ce qui se disait tout
de suite après on peut avoir de la
compassion pour les victimes
pleurer c'est ce qu'on fait en ce moment
essayé de tenir compte un peu de ce qui
s'est passé dans la tête de ces gens qui
se sont retrouvés prisonniers dans dans
les deux tours mais depuis cet événement
il s'est passé deux guerres les
américains se sont comportés comme des
deux véritables fumier on peut le dire
cesser c'est indéfendable
on ne peut défendre qu'une idée de
l'amérique mais une idée ou vieillotte
qui qui appartient à des à des vieux
ringards qui voit l'amérique comme à
l'époque du western tu vois ou alors
comme des golden boys des années 80 mais
l'amérique aujourd'hui n'est plus celle
d'avant le 11 septembre
ça ne dérange pas que je réponde à un
moment on a effectivement moi je suis
aussi ton amie et quand tu as publié un
livre après le 11 septembre intitulé une
lueur d'espoir j'ai été choqué j'étais
choquée j'ai trouvé ça avec la
couverture publicitaire elle aussi avec
les le cloud 0 avec marc et une lueur
d'espoir je trouve que voilà je peux
être ami avec toi et n'être d'accord sur
rien ça ne me dérange pas je peux quand
même boire un verre avec toi si tu veux
c'est que nous en parlons mais au delà
de 2 des excuse moi de te répondre
- longuement que toi mais quand même un
petit peu je trouve d'abord je n'ai
jamais dit que nous étions tous
américains c'est jean marie colombani
moi j'ai pas écrit ça il ya aucun moment
écrit ça mais en revanche c'est vrai que
on peut avoir de la compassion on peut
aussi considérer que l'amérique ne fait
pas que des erreurs y compris depuis le
11 septembre on en espérant un miracle
on n'ira ni n'at-elle pas fait si tu
veux mais par exemple par exemple virer
saddam hussein et essayer d'analyser
mocratie mesalles moyenne aucune
démocratie possible en irak de toute
façon pour un très très longtemps et
c'est ils n'ont pas voulu virer saddam
hussein pour imposer la démocratie il ya
une puérile it et si tu veux et je
trouve que tu lui que tu devrais te
réveiller au monde
moi je pense que c'est de l'art g et
c'est extrêmement ringard aujourd'hui de
défendre des fans elle est fort c'est la
démocratie et sert à rien c'est pas la
démocratie ni la liberté l'amérique face
et c'est tellement évident aujourd'hui
moins que jamais pardonné millions et
des millions d'arabes ac et loire qui
qui qui qui souffrent de 7 de celle des
sentiments de la mort quand il disait
moi je dirai tout est compliqué s'il
vous plaît je suis concerné le
réseautage est dire si on pouvait virer
tous les dictateurs je serai bien mais
on ne peut pas virer des dictateurs au
choix de celui qui est le plus facile à
virer exactement dire que moi je pense
que par exemple que j'ai beaucoup plus
dangereux la situation en corée du nord
tout le monde le sait et au pakistan
surtout parce que le pakistan et y aura
un coup d'état ça c'est sûr et c'est les
islamistes qui vont prendre le pouvoir
il faut enlever musharraf et là ils
auront les bons bateaux normes et la
première chose qu'ils vont faire céder
donnaient d'évidents son bouquin qui a
tué daniel pearl
je répondais à mark edwards qui moi je
considère que l'amérique c'est
effectivement la liberté la démocratie
que ils nous ont libérés des nazis en 44
que nous on les a libérés aussi des
anglais bien avant tu ne paies qui
attire toujours des liens entre nous non
la mériterais faut seulement des types
qui sont venus nous libérer des nazis
c'est ça il faut avancer avec l'histoire
l'histoire avance au monde ce qui
signifie que les ont libérés un jeu
remet d'un dictateur qu'il est temps
c'est sûr que tu es toi tu es invité par
le
mais bien évidemment ça mais voyagera
mais j'ai jamais été invité par l'état
on notera quand même pas tout à l'heure
évidemment dans ce qui paraît que c'est
que ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
le 11 septembre puisque on est vraiment
très proche de ces cérémonies la whey ce
11 septembre n'est pas un crime
au sens propre du mot c'est un châtiment
dire que les arabes ont voulu punir
l'amérique c'est pas un acte gratuit
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre il ya
tout un passé l'histoire n'a pas
commencé seulement le 11 septembre peut
pas justifier ce n'est pas jean ne peut
pas le terrorisme justifient de
l'expliquer moi ce que je voudrais et ça
c'est quand même à un de mes combats
depuis longtemps c'est qu'on arrête à un
moment donné de pleurnicher de faire des
romans à l'intérieur de la tête de ceux
qui sont des victimes de davis des
vilains arables et des méchants arabes
qui qui torturent et qui a faim qui qui
assassine tout le monde et qu'on essaye
de comprendre pourquoi il y a il ya des
actes pareils juste sur le désespoir a
poussé ddd des êtres humains à se
crasher sur des avions à dos avec des
avions dans des immeubles et ans et
enfants faire périr d'autres bien cette
réponse là elle existe dans la politique
est d'ailleurs ce qu'on fait croire on
fait croire que le que que les arabes
sont des islamistes par exemple que ce
sont des actes islamistes c'est pas
parce que ben laden est un religieux
dans sa propre et éthique de vie on va
dire qu'il a fait ses actes par religion
il a fait ces actes comme réponse
politique c'est la politique occidentale
qui a poussé certains à rabat s'extrait
mise et c'est ça la vérité je ne pense
pas que le fait de sueur c'est les
arabes qui ont fait taire au comice je
crée mon but 11 septembre
ce ne sont pas les arabes ce sont
quelques arabes certains arabes
beaucoup d'arabes presque à penser par
exemple que ces religieux comme c'est
souvent 10 ou que ces politiques comme
le dit marc et religieux du tout c'est
contre la religion islamique
complètement contre c'est interdit par
la religion c'est bien à beaucoup de
musulmans qui sont morts dans la dans le
11 septembre dans la tour les détours 40
et donc ça n'a rien à voir par exemple
quelque chose à dents dans mon roman
précédent qui s'appelait 99 francs
que j'ai écrit en 97 entre 97 et 99 a
donc avant le 11 septembre
je parlais énormément de l'hégémonie
américaine des multinationales de la
publicité et j'imaginais un acte
terroriste sur le sol américain
puisqu'il y avait un meurtre d'une
vieille dame en floride qui avait des
fonds de pension et qui était jugée
comme la responsable du malheur humain
et j'essayais de caricaturer déjà 7
cette façon un petit peu primaire de
montrer du doigt les américains comme
les responsables de nos malheurs
oui je crois si le tas tout un peu
simpliste et démagogique excuses le
magot j allais aussi dans ceux dans ton
camp si on peut dire puisque à un moment
donné tu fais tu poses la question tu te
demandes si c'est si les kamikazes ne
sont pas finalement des [ __ ]
fanatisés étudie et bien mais je fais un
oui un questionnaire à choix multiples
je trouve que ce oui non mais cc c'est
dommage avec l'az au mage qui est qui
est mort je ne savais pas stalinien
c'est nouveau chez toi oui alors au
départ c'étaient des amis si vous aussi
vous voulez vous entretenez avec votre
meilleure amie venait sur ce club vient
alors marc édouard votre livre s'appelle
printemps de feu avec un bandeau au nab
à bagdad c'est publié aux éditions du
rocher
dès les premières pages effectivement
vous affichez votre anti occidentalisme
par exemple vous êtes en syrie avant
d'aller à bagdad
et vous dites le pays qui fait trembler
les démocrates de mon hexagone honteux
si vous voulez il ya une une heure une
humanisation terrible de ce qu'est
véritablement les ce sont les problèmes
orientaux une fois qu'on les a vaincus
de l'intérieur il n'y a passé que ce
côté manichéen saisir d'un côté la vie
il ya le bien le bien c'est à dire c'est
l'occident
l'occident avait malgré ses défauts la
démocratie la liberté malgré ses défauts
qui sont des grands mots derrière
lesquels finale dure
la turbine ces masques c'est que lorsque
la dure stature venir un exemple précis
gens très sympas danemark en irak du
temps tu n'aurais pas dû dire mais ça
n'aurait pas vu ça ne suffit pas alors
il ya conservé la seconde en deux par
les médias un ventilateur
il ya plusieurs façons de torture et
j'en aurai viola défilent devant soi la
démocratie j'ai pas de filles la
démocratie la démocratie ond fils à
d'autres à d'autres manières de torture
et les gens et de leur intime et le
silence et il faudrait quand même en
prendre conscience
même la liberté de ces klein naturel
libériens par exemple qui a vu en irak
était une caricature de dictature était
une était une dictature tout à fait
horrible et qui a duré 30 ans pendant un
temps personne n'a rien fait tout le
monde aurait pu essayer de l'arrêter
saddam hussein
il a aidé tout le monde il a permis à
beaucoup de continent y compris les
américains et les européens de continuer
à s'engraisser à ceux à ceux à sa se
gaver de pétrole et à faire la guerre
par exemple aux iraniens et c'est alors
si on voulait vraiment arrêter un
dictateur ganador plein d'autres on
n'avait qu'à le faire on n'attendait pas
qu'ils ont septembre et qui est un type
comme george bush qui décide par des
raisons quasi freudienne ou pathologique
d'aller dégommer la gueule d'un type
comme saddam hussein parce qu'il n'avait
pas réussi à le faire avec son propre
père haussement d'épaulés s'impose même
chez vous vous avez en syrie quand les
premières frappes sur bagdad ont lieu
vous cherchez un taxi pour bagdad avec
sherazade donc est une danseuse que que
vous embarquer comme ça une danse une
formidable qui a eu le tort qu'ils aient
le courage des îles courageux me suivre
la balle passée avec elle ne dit pas que
c'est pas de la provocation
quand vous arrivez à la douane irakienne
vous voyez des drapeaux palestiniens et
les drapeaux irakiens et vous dites
quelle émotion
oui parce que parce que justement c'est
je trouve ça très émouvante qu'un pays
comme l'irak qui n'est pas forcément
concernés par le problème palestinien
parce que c'est très nationalistes
palestiniens et bien aide symboliquement
les palestiniens dans leur combat je
trouve ça très bien saddam hussein
c'est pas moi qui vais défendre saddam
hussein jeu j'ai horreur des dictatures
je suis un anarchiste moi je suis obligé
de reconnaître que le lieu que derrière
le tyran sanguinaire il ya 30 ans 40 ans
d'histoire et donc ça se fait pas comme
ça c'est pas juste une caricature on en
fait une sorte de l'opel voyez alors dit
saddam hussein s'éteint c'est un gros
porc un dégueulasse d'accord pour ceux
qui en subit quand souffert de lui ok
mais il s'inscrit dans toute une
situation voilà alors quand vous arrivez
à bagdad je vais un peu vite comme ça
arriver à bagdad va aussi céder c'est
laisser les journalistes vous dites ils
sont filmés fatigué devant des mosquées
pour faire couleur locale et on met un
peu de fumée pour faire effet guère les
journalistes rapport dans les six mois
simplement vous dire que par rapport aux
journalistes qui ont été tués la base
c'est terrible oui non c'est pas les
mêmes
la légion cunault d'abord aux cochons il
n'a été tué les juristes ont été
exécutés un par l'armée américaine pour
les faire taire il y avait des gens
d'ailleurs dont je parle des
journalistes qui sont très très
honorable et qui ont fait très bien leur
métier c'est à dire ceux qui avaient le
plus de distance avec avec la situation
mais ce qui se baladait avec des vestes
safari avec les peler l'étude et vous
avez les blés poche multi les peler le
lave est multipoches avec les crayons
le petit appareil photo et qui était
complètement encadrés par le basque il
faut savoir qu ils payer d'abord ce tous
les jours pour avoir le droit d'aller
voir des monuments détruits des
immeubles etc et il n'avait rien le
droit de dire et ils obéissaient aux
basses au garde à vous parce qu'ils
crient ils crient
c'est intéressant
c'est intéressant mais c'est très fort
et de toujours dans la même oreille
celle ci a peu passionné
non alors là vous êtes alors là ce même
de la provocation c'est à dire que vous
avez tort de souligner que mon livre
soit disant al ahly provocateur parce
que maintenant attendez marquer le vrai
que c'était un livre plutôt objectif
marquer c'est vrai que j'ai marqué lois
lane drouillard mais non vous défendez
le port du voile
vous savez bien que ça va apparaitre ici
comme de la provo finalement d'être
finalement eu finalement laissez moi
parler vous dites que matt en orient
désormais aux andelys ton âge là bas
vous dites vous dites que pour un
irakien finalement montré le montrer le
visage de sa femme
c'est aussi obscène que montrer son
vagin et vous dites que le voile sert à
ce qu'on regarde d'abord les femmes
comme des êtres humains à vous avez dit
théorique de boue tout ça c'est penser
c'est que je veux dire bonjour ici on
est là aussi on est on est dans une dans
un état et un continent où tout est vu
selon le le son problème moral et sa
propre pratique delà de la civilisation
on croit que c'est ça la section voile à
omar sharif
garcia lille égyptien mais est ce que
voit il dit que finalement le port du
voile enfin lui comprendre très bien il
dit que c'est très bien parce que ça
évite quand on regarde les femmes comme
des objets sexuels que c'est chez
l'homme a blanchi pas envie de les
dénuder et finalement le fait de
dévoiler ses de l'est c'est une forme de
respect s'est déconsidéré finalement à
des êtres humains et non pas comme des
objets sexuels je fais contre si on
oblige une femme à porter le voile je
suis contre non mais si elle veut et
qu'elle a envie de porter le voile ou
qu'elle a envie de porter une écharpe
pour qu'elle a envie de porter un
foulard ou qu'elle a envie de porter un
soutien gorge ou pas bien ça la regarde
voilà ça y est je suis con l'effort
[Applaudissements]
bien alors on continue pour rencontrer
un prêtre à bagdad
qui vous dit vous êtes un petit peu vous
finalement un catholique islamique et
vous dites publier absolument je suis un
catholique islamique j'avais tellement
entendu scène ces rapprochements de mots
comme ça et vous dites je suis contre l'
empire protestante ya évidemment vous
sentez plus de 2 de proximité entre les
catholiques et les musulmans je suis je
suis pas un musulmane aux maniaques
oui je dois je suis obligé de
reconnaître et je ne suis pas le seul
que c'est dans l'islam qui a aujourd'hui
le plus de fois et que c'est le seul la
seule religion qui pourrait être
peut-être un jour en quand on aura purgé
de ses excès je suis bien d'accord
la seule région qui pourra être
révolutionnaire et révolutionnaire
contre quoi et bien contre l' empire du
fric
l' empire de la superficialité de la
mondanité delà de la frivolité de la
futilité sont visés n'avait résistants
d'aujourd'hui qui sont les résistants
d'aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas les
américains se sont pas les laits l'ailé
les fils de bush se sont pas ceux qui
prônent un an 1,1 occidentalisme
suffisant et arrogant et résistant
aujourd'hui on le sait bien ce sont ceux
qu'on n'a pas et ce sont aussi les
musulmans qui essayent de défendre leurs
couleurs terre où leur foi
d'accord je suis désolé mais je pense
que c'est un volume réduit la peine de
se battre pour la frivolité pour la
superficialité pour la liberté
ça vaut la peine
tu
il ya un combat plus nomme lire dans la
vie que de se battre pour plus de
superficialité
je pense que la légèreté c'est une
valeur et je suis prêt à mourir pour
elle
je pense que cette espèce de puritanisme
dont tu te fais le héros soudain tout
d'un coup ça me contraire je suis contre
le puritanisme puritanisme c'est
l'oeuvre des protestants justement c'est
l'oeuvre de sept grands empires
protestants qui se met en route
voilà on peut pas trouver plus puritains
que aujourd'hui les protestants qui se
permettent d'aller d'aller dégommer la
gueule d'une civilisation qui a des
centaines et des centaines de soldats
noirs fois derrière eux une superbe on
dirait andré malraux je t'adore mais
simplement j'aurais quand même te dire
ce que j'ai fait ce que j'ai déjà dit au
début de l'émission
je crois qu'il faut pas être trop simple
c'est compliqué tous les américains ne
sont pas d'accord avec george bush
les américains sont un peuple
extrêmement critique les artistes
américains sont très subversif il ya
michael mauriac sean penn il ya
énormément de gens aux états unis qui ne
sont pas d'accord avec george bush ne
résume pas l'ami lola se faire la guerre
et ses réserves est impardonnable c'est
vers là on ne va pas mais il faut qu'on
arrête avec ce discours en disant au
moins ils ont fait chuter saddam hussein
ne sert à rien il est 6 h à la salle
jean dunand il n'a pas été pris le
bourbier continuer pour mieux analyser
des raisons tu vas basile demain puis
valeur de maintenant
j'ai trop peur de rencontrer alors à ce
point du rendement il faut voter à
sevrey du roman marc et noir découvre
que la danseuse du ventre shéhérazade et
la fille de saddam hussein 1
et vous vous rencontrez saddam hussein
qui vous révèle des choses qu'on ne
savait pas voilà sur le koweït et sur
ses deux jambes qu'il a fait tuer voilà
voilà
alors suis suis une éloge de la sodomie
hétérosexuels parce que cette pauvre
sherazade y passent donc là ça c'est pas
bien je n'ai pas peur au contraire
j'adore le personnage de sherazade elle
est très très elle et elle est très au
contraire très bien servi et alors au
final donc pas la bataille annoncée vous
êtes très déçu parce que vous y allez
pour ça vous allez pour pour vivre sous
les sous les bombes comme comme à dresde
on pourrait dire exactement et donc d'un
seul coup une victoire acheter puisque
oui vous dit que finalement on va vous
l'avez su après mais donc moi j'avais eu
des informations là bas que évidemment
donc le lit l'irak fallait les
américains commençaient à arriver vers
bagdad et voyant qu'il y avait des ddd
plus que des poches de résistance à
bassorah et à nadjaf et bien donc cette
victoire allait être impossible
la bataille de bagdad allait s'enliser
pendant plusieurs semaines est toujours
très courageusement les américains alors
qu'on arrête de les faire passer pour
des super technicien et des très grands
combattants
ils sont allés apporter une mallette de
dollars à sofiane al tikriti qui est le
cousin de chef de la république et voilà
de saddam il a pris la mallette et il a
demandé à toute l'armée de ne pas
combattre
ils sont entrés en un quart d'heure
vingt minutes près
je pense que marc edouard nabe a
toujours eu bien aimé se s'installer
dans des positions assez contradictoire
provocatrice et et scandaleuse par par
goût de je ne sais pas par certains
certes un messianisme masochiste un goût
du sacrifice et et voilà donc là il a
trouvé quelque chose de nouveau avant
c'était j'ai pas dire du mal des juifs
ou je sais pas quoi puis la ccsa donc
maintenant ben voilà c'est julien donne
rien à dire que c'est pour moi c'est on
sort de la littérature
on sort de la littérature ce qui est
important c'est les phrases les mots le
style peu importe en effet non non c'est
moche c'est que c'est nous autres
acteurs on se déchire aussi quand ils me
prennent merola quartier maïs guézy
reçoivent à l'oscar est pas mal
[Musique]
nab à bagdad c'est tout
éditions du rocher à mes yeux
ça va bien ça va bien aller oui ah oui
sache que tu veux tu dois revenir car tu
as la carte de bons clients maris femmes
seules et de cheval quand tu vois la
très belle entier merci beaucoup
à
j'espère qu andré glucksmann sera
rétabli la semaine prochaine et qui sera
parmi nous voilà alors maintenant je
vais rejoindre quelqu'un qui refusent
pour des raisons de sécurité un peu
comme vous l'a la semaine dernière
fabrique bd et d'apparaître sur un
plateau de télévision avec du avec du
public
elle s'appelle ni maamar c'est une ex
espionne israélienne et vous allez voir
elle balance tout
[Musique]
à
il
[Musique]
on soit en service en concert demain
soir alors j'ai voulu qu'on se retrouve
ici c'est pour des raisons de sécurité
que tu préfères effectivement qui pak
public autour
quand je fais une télévision - vous avez
peur d'être reconnue oui ni maze a marre
c'est pas votre vrai nom c'est mon nom
c'est mon identité réelle sur le terrain
alors vous êtes juive française famille
d'origine roumaine cessa exterminés dans
l'est dans les camps nazis est à 22 ans
vous décidez de faire votre alias c'est
à dire votre retour en israël
absolument pourquoi c'était pour moi une
évidence
en tant que juive et puis parce qu'il me
retenait plus rien en france je pensais
que c'était bien me refaire ma vie
entièrement de cet indiscret vous ai
vécu jusqu'à 22 en france vous avez un
accent quand même si possible j'ai
tellement d'accent si vous saviez alors
comment israël tant qu'on n'a pas fait
son service militaire on n'est pas
vraiment intégré des ressources voilà
vous faites votre service
et puis pour vous c'est aussi une façon
de prendre votre revanche sur votre mère
qui avait été tellement traumatisée par
parler quand oui que chaque fois qu'elle
voyait un uniforme elle elle était
complètement paniquée oui c'est vrai
c'était une façon de nettoyer un passé
douloureux
je pensais faire un service simple pas
du tout un vice de combat ou d'un
service quoi que ce soit toujours le
service où on donne des cours aux civils
ou des choses comme ça un service
tranquille alors quand vous êtes
ingénieur en informatique dans l'armée
israélienne bah vous vous avez travaillé
sur l'informatique et et vous trouver la
faille du système informatique
ouais c'est à dire que tout d'un coup
l'officier arrive un soir et il m'a dit
qu'il a perdu afficher une machine sur
un réseau et me demande comme un service
si je peux pas le dépanner j'avais
l'impression que ça risque d'être un
piège bien sûr un peu gros mais d'un
autre côté je pouvais pas refuser
et puis je me suis pris au jeu en même
temps effectivement j'ai réussi à casser
la faille du service enfin la sécurité
du réseau
c'est pas difficile à casser et alors là
vos supérieurs vous leurs proches après
c'est après qu'on voulait demander on
vous le reproche et on exerce sur vous
une forme de chantage en vous disant
maintenant si tu veux pas être poursuivi
m qu'une chose à faire finalement c'est
travail points voilà absolument exact
fait piéger oui je me suis fait piéger
mais le premier pas est forcément
souvent je n'étais pas la seule à qui ça
mais ensuite le dès le lendemain on est
complètement pris en charge par toute
une équipe qui vous soutient
psychologiquement qui s'entraîne
physiquement qui vous parle de votre
action du sens qu'elle peut avoir du
service que vous avez rendre au [ __ ] dit
que vous allez sauver et c'est fini je
vais dire le chantage ça dure quoi
séduire une journée ouais c'est juste un
pas à franchir que je n'aurais jamais
franchi moi même je ne serais pas engagé
je ne serai pas postuler pour une place
dans ce genre de service et ensuite j'ai
continué par par patriotisme
alors là vous subissez une formation
dans le but d'infiltrer le hesbollah le
hesbollah tu sais les milice chiite
libanaise alors vous apprenez à endurer
des passages à tabac par exemple comment
ça se passe graduellement et ça prend
beaucoup de temps
c'est un entraînement qui se fait pour
pas braquer les gens pour pas qu'il y
ait de révolte non plus franches on
s'habitue graduellement à des coûts il
faut bien dire comme celle des coûts
j'ai pas non plus rentrer dans le détail
parce que bon c'est particulièrement
pénible et puisse rentrer dans ce genre
de service c'est un passage obligé de
dix ans le mot de subir nous torturent
pas ouais jusque là jusqu'à la torture
et le lavage de cerveau c'est pourquoi
j'ai parlé de lavage de cerveau j'ai pas
varié la magie certes il tue par les
doctrines mans c'est différent quand
même pas tellement non c'est vrai que
c'est tellement difficile
psychologiquement de tenir le coup
d'abord parmi des gens pour ne respecte
pas qu'on estime pas j'ai par des
terroristes pas des palestiniens ne me
fait pas faux procès je n'accuse pas les
palestiniens je ne sais tu pas les
palestiniens mais c'est sûr quand on est
dans les groupes terroristes qui sont
violents ivres de haine
un monde un milieu socialement
donc là je n'avais pas l'habitude quand
même moi j'ai vécu en france au départ
certain confort jeu il faut ne pas
oublier pourquoi on travaille donc c'est
vrai que ce que vous appelez donc lavage
de cerveau ce que j'appelle un autre
humain parce que jérôme soutien
psychologique
c'est c'est ce que j'ai mis en fait d'un
tout au long du livre ce sale caractère
graal et les récits des attentats qui
s'en produit pendant ces dix ans vous
montre des photos l'on vous montre des
films on est en éveil votre haine contre
ces terroristes non c'est pas de la
haine c'est vraiment pas de l'âne c'est
la conscience de ce qu'on peut apporter
pour sauver des vies vous voyez ça je
tiens absolument à marquer ça il ya une
différence
je ne fais pas ce métier pour détruire
des palestiniens ou des terroristes on
fait ce métier pour construire l'état
d'israël et sauver des vies et si cette
psychologie leur que nous avons alors
ensuite une fois que la formation est
terminée on vous introduit donc au
hezbollah ou fait passer pour pour une
fille assez riche en héritière de
palestiniens émigrés ans en suisse et
qui a envie de consacrer sa fortune à
aider ils ont cru oui oui penser qu'ils
sont naïfs non je pensais qu'une pense
se gérer la situation de façon et puis
ça les intéresse
lorsque vous dit qui est assez critique
pour la pole pour la france au site
ayant été élevé avec les idées de la
gauche française
finalement j'ai pas eu de mal
ah d'accord avec enfin tous les cas leur
faire croire que j'étais d'accord avec
eux oui c'est ça je connaissais le
discours je connais certains discours
programme pro palestiniens donc j'ai pas
eu de mal à répéter ce discours quand
j'étais pas mieux c'est vrai alors après
six mois avec ces palestiniens vous
partez dans un camp d'entraînement du
hezbollah en libye et la bauche f vous
ordonne et c'est un des moments les plus
j'avais moins plus fort du bouquin et
vous ordonne de d'assassiner une
combattante de votre âge qui s'appelle
yasmina et sans sourciller vous vous
l'étrangler pour moi mon métier au
départ c'est l'informatique intégrée
c'est arrivé à pirater ses ordinateurs
il fallait que je m'attelle dans un
groupe de terrorisme pour les rejoindre
effectivement le passage obligé c'était
ce camp d'entraînement ça voulu dire
obéir à leurs codes obéir à leurs règles
et jouer le jeu comme un combattant il
ya dans ces camps d'entraînement un
processus de déshumanisation qui est
très important qui est même le plus
important c'est pas tellement des décors
paramilitaires ou technologies avancées
pas du tout c'est avec une amitié
détecter donné l'ordre à chacun des deux
amis de tuer l'autre et puis voir celui
qui aura le courage c'est
particulièrement cruel ça a été décrit
par d'autres que par mois mais bon les
gens mais vous au moment où vous
l'étrangler vous pensez quoi
moi j'étais justement comme je savais
que ça avait déjà été décrit je savais
que ça risque de produire j'avais été
préparé à ça mais tout le moins la
rigueur c'était moins difficile que pour
eux parce que ils sont enfin je veux
dire que ça arrive à des palestiniens et
des libanais dans ce camp là c'est entre
je dirais même partisan du même côté
tandis que moi je suis un ennemi
quelqu'un qui allait éventuellement
mettre des bombes contre les israéliens
c'est un être humain et yasmina quand
même vous êtes c'est une guerre et pour
rentrer pour faire ce que j'avais à
faire après il fallait infiltrer ce
groupe il fallait faire ce qu il fallait
le faire donc je les fais oui mais je
les fais comme un soldat fait une
mission je veux dire j'ai pas fait
ni par plaisir ni par indifférence non
par quoi que ce soit je vous ai dit
quelque chose avant de mourir non j'ai
pas souvenir que je vous ai regardé j'ai
fais dodo à faire de face et quand même
plus difficile et le lendemain matin
vous révélions dès le soir même je t'ai
pris un rejet violent évidemment si on
fait pas non plus la première fois que
j'ai tué quelqu'un et de près je veux
dire c'est pas comme quand vous tirer
sur quelqu'un qui a à 200 m mais sûr
qu'il ya leurs projets suivants mais
comme encore une fois excusez le psycho
logiquement sauver des vies étaient plus
importants que c'est dans ces moments là
vous continuer à vivre comme une femme
c'est à dire à vous maquiller à vous
occuper de vous oui oui tous les jours
oui c'est important ça aussi ça le
lendemain les jours vous avez tué
yesmine à vous maquiller comme
normalement non pas d'un camp
d'entraînement voilà non mais après dans
le reste ma vie oui vous avez tués
combien de gens dans votre vie j'ai pas
compté combien de gens du tube on doit
bien décompté comme quand on tue des
gens c'est parce que quand vous voulez
occulter vous comptez pas juste alors là
où c'est encore plus difficile c'est
qu'à un moment vous recevez une mission
qu il vous faire arrêter pour implanter
des mouchards dans les ordinateurs des
services de sécurité syriens est alors
dans ce cas là c'est encore pire parce
que vous êtes obligé de faire attention
à ce que votre victime ne meurt pas trop
vite pour qu'elle ait le temps de
prévenir ses amis et que vous soyez
arrêté ouais mais c'est arrivé une fois
attention c'était quelqu'un qui m'avait
avant d'énoncer aux syriens comme ayant
des activités anti syrienne je me suis
fait arrêter je me suis une ordure et
interroger et c'est cette même personne
effectivement je les tue et un peu plus
tard dans l'ue conditions un peu pénible
c'est vrai mais bon c'est un cas un peu
unique exceptionnel vous a été torturé
on vous apprend à supporter la la
torture pendant votre formation vous
amène dans les hôpitaux on vous montre
des gens qui ont des cancers avancés on
vous montre des gens qui sont amputés de
façon à vous habituer et finalement à la
plaigne pas trop oui j'ai été victime de
torture chimiques c'est par injection ça
fait quel effet une douleur atroce celle
que j'avais ressenti cette douleur qui
comme comment dire aiguë qui remontaient
dû remonter le corps jusqu'au cerveau
jusqu'à voir l'impression que le coeur
ou cerveau va exploser on sait pas le
cas le veut le faire le premier c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable parce
que c'est en nous quand vous prenez un
coup ci plus supportable parce que ça
vienne extérieur est bon ça les
tortionnaires le savent très bien
c'est un monde vous avez été violée non
ça fait près les intéressés non c'est
bizarre quand même
wisair bah oui parce qu'on peut penser
captures de mots et vous torture ne
peuvent en profiter enfin je viens c'est
mais c'était pas le cas vous savez il ya
un tel mépris façon que je sais pas en
fait j'ai une idée quand ils vous
torturer il s'occupait de votre sexe oui
il ya des tortures par des matraques
électriques qui a été torturée
effectivement bien esquinté d'ailleurs
comme un prêt j'ai eu ma petite fille
c'était difficile oui alors après ça
quand vous avez quitté le ce service
donc que vous nommez pas mais dont on a
bien compris que c'était le mossad ont
envie comment dans un système vous
comprenez on n'est pas l'horizon
ouais on a une action qui ont été un
héros ou l'héroïne en tout quelque part
bien sûr et puis on a des compétences on
passe dans un autre système
ce qu'on sait faire ne sert à rien en
fait on ne sait rien fait main et en
plus on n'est pas valorisé du tout et
c'est difficile à vivre
forcément oui oui j'ai une dépression à
ce moment là une petite dépression
surtout que la sortie avait été
difficile et puis et puis j'avais eue
j'en avais assez de ces destructions de
ces violences et c'est là que j'avais
commencé justement suivre des cours de
krav maga ont permis de me reconstruire
physiquement tu ne cesses de france en
fait oui oui mais surtout ça donne à
l'individu et par le le fait qu'il
s'autorise à se défendre
pour ma part c'était défendu c'est et
politiquement incorrect mais il fallait
en kessé et pas faire de vagues
donc quand j'ai basculé dans ce
processus
d'avoir le droit d'exister d'avoir le
droit de me défendre d'avoir le droit de
vivre
c'était énorme pour moi et ça a été une
reconstruction psychologique
fondamentale psychothérapie aussi et
j'imagine fait des cauchemars encore oui
ça c'est inévitable faut que
vous voyez quoi dans ses cauchemars
des cris des des sentiments de peur ou
aussi surtout des tortures qui en israël
plus de souffrance
vous voyez des gens que vous avez tué
non sauf un qui est un tortionnaire que
tu as pris alors ensuite vous avez fait
un enfant
malheureusement son père a été tué
quelques quelques mois plus tard cédant
même service que vous vous dites
inquiètes parce que quand vous avez subi
ces tortures chimiques peut-être ya des
choses qui restaient dans votre corps
j'avais encore des crises régulièrement
la qualité la part des chemins et les
médecins non plus avait pas très moyen
parce que ouais c'est des produits assez
inconnu en même temps oui c'est puis
j'ai malheureusement ça évolue mais
l'enfant est bien merci et avec les
hommes comment ça se passe aujourd'hui
alors ça peut être formidable pour de
draguer matar ils ont tangué mathari oui
de vivre avec elles n'ont pas dit non
parce que il ya une telle
incompréhension des deux mondes
et puis moi même chez des moments de je
me replie sur moi même je pense à autre
chose et tu vois ce monde qui ne
connaissent pas et qui nous qu'elles
n'auront pas accès c'est pas possible
donc pour l'instant je n'ai pas trouvé
fonction vous êtes seul oui la solitude
convient à deux avec une incompréhension
totale de l'autre c'est encore pire donc
c'est vrai vous avez fait le livre
pourquoi j'ai fait livres pour sortir de
ce milieu et j'ai fait du livre pour
passer un message aux gens qui font le
même métier que ce processus de
reconstruction que j'ai entrepris moi
même s'ils veulent entreprendre une
mauvaise chose le père de ma fille comme
vous l'avez dit a été tué parce que
justement il suivait la politique
officielle de rester passif d'encaisser
les coups etc
il a pris un mauvais coup on avait eu
avant une discussion ensemble assez
soutenue pour essayer de le convaincre
de faire du krav maga défense qui sont
plus discrètes je veux dire si c'est
basé sur des réflexes et pas
les techniques de karaté ou pousser un
cri vous avez des gestes identifié mais
il n'avait pas voulu faire parce qu'il
tenait son avancement à être bientôt
faire une carrière et c'est donc ce que
je voudrais passer comme message au
milieu peut-être je sais que en israël
l'intérêt de l'individu de passe
derrière l'intérêt général boxer la
guerre oui mais un peu trop peut-être
remonter un tout petit peu l'intérêt
d'individus ne nuirait pas du tout à son
efficacité ce qu est le message que je
passais ça vous protège d'avoir fait ce
livre
oui parce que les ce livre je montre
quand même la moitié mon visage à
découvert et les gens qui me connaissent
me reconnaissent et mon nom et non
opérationnels sur le terrain je veux
dire à ceux du métier d'un bord comme de
l'autre
une troisième voie que j'arrête ce genre
de métier maintenant je comprends qu'il
a fait alors vous avez pas peur du
hezbollah là parce que quand même
vous avez trahi vous avez tué des leur
faisait pas peur d'aller me promener là
où ils ont un leur implantation c'est
sûr maintenant ici je vous revois non en
quoi ils viendraient le chercher
l'exploit en plus le fait de reconnaître
qu'ils ont été roulés par une femme
femme
l'horreur absolue et le menaça le mossad
vous pourriez en avoir peur parce que
vous avez été victime quand vous êtes
parti à l'aéroport
par une micro seringue comme ça d'une
tentative d'assassinât
oui mais en même temps il m'avait
prévenu donc c'est toujours c'est cette
duplicité qui a de ce genre de milieu
manipulation des gens qui est assez
forte donc c'est si on voulait me tuer
mon rituel depuis longtemps voilà ce que
je pense
alors comme vous le savez certains
mettent en doute la crédibilité de votre
votre récit d'abord le recrutement par
chantage on dit que c'est pas vrai avec
les gens comme ça oui non recrutés gens
et puis on dit aussi qu'à pas de camp
hezbollah en syrie sont plutôt au sud
liban les camps du hezbollah et c'est
bien ce que j'ai dit son fils du banc
j'ai un journaliste fait un amalgame
et puis ils sont aussi liban j'ai fait
des incursions cyril consentie quand on
dit aussi qu'à l'époque manipulés par
les syriens ont dit aussi qu'à l'époque
dont vous parlez mais pas suffisamment
d'ordinateurs en syrie pour que
quelqu'un soit envoyé pour coller des
mouchards dans ses ordinateurs non mais
c'est vrai il n'est pas d'ordinateur en
syrie d'ailleurs on n'a jamais été un
ciré et d'ailleurs je sais même pas si
ça existe là sinon non faut être
raisonnable non mais c'est tout à fait
vrai nom le ce livre pour l'écrire je
réduis atteint 30 ans à ce moment là
j'aurais pu donner des noms des lieux
des dates des précisions et puis ne pas
mettre en danger les des choses qui
peuvent éventuellement tourner encore
dans des ordinateurs qui n'existe pas
mais j'ai essayé de faire quand même un
livre parce que pour ma survie c'était
important
je remercie au passage aux éditeurs
fester maintenant michel absolument quel
courage de le publier de risquer sa
réputation
mon témoignage c'est courageux mais j'ai
essayé de pas mettre quoi que ce soit
qui puisse faire courir des risques aux
gens sur eux même si après ça m'est
reproché comme un manque de preuves
pensez pas que c'est le mossad qui fait
courir des bruits
sur la véracité de votre aventure
service secret israélien alors il ya un
truc aussi qui arrange pas la
crédibilité de votre affaire mais c'est
peut-être vrai hein ça fait un petit
rimer sens c'est que l'attentât du world
trade center auraient été commis par les
russes en fait parce que vous expliquez
que d'abord vous dites les arabes sont
incapables sur le plan technique de
faire quelque chose d'aussi difficile et
vous dites qu à part le gps finalement
le seul guidage pour tomber juste dans
les tours
c'est le glonass et le jura le guidage
russe sur rapporte une conversation que
j'avais eue avec des camarades à ce
sujet après le 11 septembre parce qu on
était tous très étonné de cette histoire
d'al qaïda je vous explique pourquoi
d'abord la façon de procéder est pas
arabe
je veux dire ce doublé précis sur des
tours c'est pas l'heure enfin détourner
un avion et le jeter au pif sur la ville
oui mais bon pour ce que nous nous
savons connaissons des arabes et
connaissant des russes
oui on avait l'impression que c'était
plutôt parce que on peut pas échapper à
des services secrets de la planète
entière pendant des années c'était un
plan qui a été monté sur des années et
c'est pas non plus dans la mentalité
arabe de prévoir des plans sur une
longue durée et le garçon dénommé zac
qui vous avait parlé de sa spécialiste
sud l'ukraine
oui et morts dans cet avion qui a été
descendu par un missile
quelques semaines plus tard évidemment
accidentellement un missile absolument
accidentel tiré par les ukrainiens donc
vous n'êtes pas mythomane vous n'êtes
pas la nouvelle nikita
non non non vraiment pas une petite non
s'il vous plaît une super espionne alors
pas super je suis quelqu'un d'ordinaire
quelqu'un d'ordinaire qui s'est retrouvé
un brin gars dans un processus et ça que
je vais décrire aussi dans ce livre
sachez aussi faire attention dans quoi
vous mettez les pieds parce que on pense
toujours à moi ça n'arrivera pas et moi
je n'en veux pas moi je ne fais rien de
tout ça et puis en fait pas prêt pas on
se retrouve impliqué dans des histoires
il faut bien pour avoir conscience que
ça prend des années c'est pas du jour au
lendemain si c'était à refaire
j'espère que ce sera parfait vous
échappent eux rien le lendemain du jour
où vous ont mis sur le dos le l'histoire
l'ordinateur probablement vous allez
faire quoi là ce soir c'est soir ouais
je suis retrouvé ma petite fille et puis
je vais bientôt partir loin au soleil je
sais pas on va arriver dans l'hiver de
façon non mais je sais je sais j'essaye
de refermer trouver un métier trouver
une vie normale merci
[Musique]
non
alors j'ai pas eu brûlé vise maintenant
il ya mata hari sa fin mais c'est au cas
laetitia qu'il fallait faire des
émissions masquait mal reçus mais ouais
ouais mais non j'en sais rien c'est vrai
que moi au moins j'ai l'honnêteté
d'écrire un roman sur la couverture de
mon livre on sait que c'est inventé
je sais pas non j'en sais rien je marque
et loire je me sens plus proche d'elle
que de n'importe quel écrivain français
vivent et ce qui est ce qui est très
intéressant de voir c'est un peu ce que
j'ai tout à l'heure c'est que c'est une
combattante et ça n'empêche pas d'être
légère d'être avoir du charme de de rire
et tout en étant extrêmement profonde
elle a dit est d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
elle a dit c'est la guerre et la raison
c'est la guerre alors vous auriez
interrogé un kamikaze palestinien
il vous aurait certainement raconté à
peu près la même chose dans l'autre camp
il ya aussi des gens qui sont des jeunes
gens qui croient encore à quelque chose
et préférait pas que ces gens-là et
envie de faire la paix plutôt que la
guerre c'est pas l'heure de la paix
c'est l'heure de la guerre et il faut
qu'il y ait des gens qui ce qui con
comme elle même si je suis absolument
pas d'accord à ce qu'elle a épuisé
culture impliqué alors dans moi je sais
pas si c'est vrai aussi c'est faux ça
m'a un peu fait froid dans le dos quand
on racontait ces exécutions
et puis je comprends pas qu'on puisse
épouser des idées jusqu'au point de tuer
moi je pense qu'il faut aussi traversé
la vie sans tuer personne enfin moi
c'est un minimum garanti quoi dans sur
cette personne et ça m'a rappelé une
scène de 2
deux films l'armée des ombres qu'en
abandonnant il faut tuer un collabo et
qui sait dire ça au sort et ça c'est
très très stressant et prenante mais
c'est son histoire vraie qui sont
vraiment passé mais qui pose des cas de
conscience à tout le monde quoi bien
merci à tous et puis j'espère qu'elle
s'en sortira pas ce qu'elle est très
très inquiétant
et maintenant
[Musique]
voici marion cotillard et guillaume
canet
[Musique]
bonsoir marion
maliki et toi qu'est ce qui te prends ça
va ça va bien aller dakar c'est quoi le
rôle c'est un art connectique assez
narcos non sérieusement bien qu'ils
n'entendaient un petit peu après 10h
york
ouais arrête et j'ai vu à new york il
est dans mon livre ah oui c'est vrai
j'ai brigué dernier dans mon lit sorti
sur la santé de l'idole c'est ça non un
festival de new york ouais ouais et
alors les gens ont bien accueilli ça a
été super bien ouais mais ça supermarché
ce film ça fait six ans milan très
pratique et je vous dis oui chers amis
téléspectateurs que c'est en vente en
dvd voilà bien alors pour le moment on
vous retrouve tous les deux à l'affiché
d'un film de yann samuell qui s'appelle
jeu d'enfant et qui sort le 17 septembre
est une comédie romantique décalée
le pitch moi si je devais résumer ce
film je dirais tu t'es pas cap' parce
qu'ils passent leur temps les deux le
couple depuis leur plus jeune âge
jusqu'à des années plus tard à se lancer
des défis
d'une certaine façon c'est ça non oui
pour ce fou pour se prouver leur amour
enfin la saison se passe le dire ils
sont ils sont amis au départ et en fait
il se cache cet amour en se lançant des
défis et des cas poids il ya une boîte
c'est quoi cette boîte dans l'île en
fait quand un ensemble défi à l'autre et
que l'autre relève le défi et récupère
la boîte et c'est à son tour de donner
un nouveau décollage et qu'il a besoin
de jouer jusqu'à 35 balais quand même
voilà alors il ya des défis d'enfants
qui continuent à l'âge adulte
par exemple vous étiez engagé à ce qu' à
dire non le jour de votre mariage
et finalement vous dites oui et elle
arrive elle fait un scandale donc on
voit que ça dure très très tard et là
après vous met encore un défi et vous
voyez pas pendant dix ans quoi mais
c'est un cercle vicieux enfin manie
peuvent plus faire marche arrière
messieurs je vais voir ce qui se passe
en club à savoir à propos une belle
transition je reviens je préfère les
espionnes
nous voilà prêts c'est un cercle vicieux
peut plus faire marche arrière et donc
leur cap vieillissent avec eux et ça
devient de plus en plus grave pour eux
et leur entourage quoi et c'est vrai que
c'est quoi comme des filles se jettent
pardon je prends un peu la relève en has
been de la télé j'ai encore des filles
jaffe l'animateur exemple de défi
exemple de défis un moment je dois lui
parler de lui ramener les lébous
d'oreilles d'une charmante jeune fille
qui va passer son examen et je la
culbute plutôt dans les toilettes
enfin voilà le défi à relever est le
défi relevé oui merveilleusement relevé
bien répondu non j'ai bien fait
d'arrêter ce métier je viens comme aussi
avec une jolie boîte et jolie copine qui
sofiane est la boîte a quand même donné
la porte n gage gars pompe à 4 c'est
parti comme ça vraiment commencé cup
je t'aimais 0 tu m'entends c'est comme 0
discipline est la mère du respect et
sans respect nous séparer donc jamais
été capturé sophie moi j'ai bien dormi
dix ans et plus et on atteint les choses
sérieuses ont commencé cap ou pas cap -
3 m² de m + 1
attendons
pour cambrai ce mois
sur des mariés
d'accord
[Musique]
d'accord c'est tout et moi mon mariage
julien antoine janvier consensus à
prendre pour épouse christelle louise
bouchard
julien à c'était juste une blague je
crois qu'elle est obligée
je voudrais qu'on parlement bien jeu
geffray
ça fait
tu as fait
voilà jeunes enfants les aiment ce duel
avec marion petit 1
avec guillaume qu'à l'émission l'invité
ce soir voilà c'est vrai quand on voit
la bande annonce on comprend mieux de
quoi il retourne laurent vous êtes
arrivé ip oui guéri je suis en quarts et
avec qui et du moule au rang des gens
que je ne connais pas j'ai j'ai reconnu
annie lemoine carrément topless est bon
là les gens commencent à rire mais sinon
c'est assez plombé les gens sont maires
de grave derrière géraldine maillet à
côté de vous il ya gilles martin
chauffier thomert sisley qui fait la
rubrique des jeunes mâles alphas
sympathique qui rit mais le courant ne
passe pas mais laurent est ce que au
moins vous pouvez leur demander s'ils
ont envie d'aller voir ce film qui
ressemble mais je n'ai manqué ici tirer
tout le monde a envie d'aller voir ce
film
il ya un côté amélie poulain dans ce
même sens et non il ya un côté guy lux
et citronné recherche
non je ne vous entends bhl et
j'ai cassé mes lunettes pour assurer ma
famille
oui laurent oui vous restez là bas vous
prenez soin de nous inviter bien sûr
mais il ya des gens âgés dont il faut
s'occuper
on est là pour ça vous intervenez quand
vous voulez laurent bien sûr tirer tout
de suite a tout de suite mon petit le
bien alors marion jeu quand je veux ça
peut être maintenant bien sûr trop tôt
qui érige la candeur mais quand tu veux
c'est quand tu veux laurent a tout de
suite
ouais d'accord marie on avait fait ce
choix l'éléphant les économies sur la
clim là j'ai l'impression mais c'est un
peu tard alors marion quand vous êtes
présentée au casting vouliez absolument
ce rôle ça c'est une vraie question
d'animateurs a créé la lépi rien fait
mais qui anime une émission de cinéma ce
mario houle vous lis euros le volume ce
rôle si je vous laisse voilà ouais vous
étiez pas tout ça de côté et je n'étais
pas tout seul
battu qui je ne sais pas tout les toutes
les vedettes de paris ouverte à régler
était furieuse qu'il avait à mon nom
ça vous a plu cet acharnement désespéré
a pas vouloir sortir de l'enfance a
refusé une vie normale ça vous a plu la
naïveté du film qui nous intéresse c'est
la naïveté oui aussi la cruauté la
perversion la nation vous avez remarqué
d'éditeurs version jj sur guillaume
bélanger entendu ta vanne sur un monde à
lire ce que tu voudrais prendre ma place
c'est très mal victoire jean sève monte
à bord et un an je n'aurais jamais ce
ton talent jamais alors vous il paraît
guillaume peut pas vous étiez enfant
vous étiez pire que l'on y aura de quoi
faire
c'est bien c'est vrai vous cambrioler
des supermarchés que vous êtes chez
petit nom brille pour des bonbons ah oui
c'est tout des bonbons et des bouteilles
consignées en fait on avait réussi à
ouvrir le local je sens que ça vous fait
chier parce que je sais qu'il ya eu des
trucs non parce que je sais qu'après ya
eu des trucs moins avouables et vous ne
voulez pas les dire je comprends pas la
wii
non c'est normal pourquoi parce que
c'est un petit peu sexuelle tout ça donc
je peux raconter
c'est à l'époque où il s'est acheté ce
mois ci décidera s'il est là qu est ce
qui s'est passé après sa gueule tu peux
y aller la personne est décédée
maintenant c'est ce qui s'est passé gay
non mais c'est rien passé du tout c'est
des conneries d'enfants
c'est très commun à tous mais il faudra
que des vieilles pour leur piquer leurs
sacs
voilà je fais ça guillaume enfin c'est
pas la peine qu'on les vieux arrêté ma
mère regardé samedi soir donc avait dit
quelque chose il te reste avec moi
thierry
non non c'est annie lemoine hervé
guillaume gagnon s'est amusé sur canal i
l était drivé est super mais oui mario
aura continué à faire une vrai interview
cinéma est ce que vous regrettez que les
séries taxi et finalement un petit peu
occulté votre votre talent de comédienne
non je regrette pas je fais mon chemin
tranquillement 1 1 et
je suis plutôt que l'on contente du
chemin que je fais pour l'instant si
c'était à refaire je referais pas tout
mais je change si c'était à refaire vous
referiez combien de taxi bas 3 1 a peur
changerait rien ouais d'accord mais là
vous êtes formidable ce soir là je vous
disais moi extrêmement séduisante
c'est un truc c'est plus combien de
temps c'est parce que j'avais dit que
c'était violent
voilà mais je ne sais pas du tout c'est
très beau merci beaucoup ça sort d'où ça
sort de mon armoire bien et vous avez su
pendant le service public c'est ça c'est
fou ce qu'on apprend dans cette émission
c'est incroyable les gens comprennent
pourquoi ils paient en oeuvre ce que tu
sais quoi vous ai fait un film avec tim
burton
oui c'est énorme comment ça s'est passé
alors il est venu rencontrer des
comédiennes françaises à paris parce que
c'était le rôle d'une française et tais
toi laurent oui elle donnerait un petit
plat doute topless un élan géraldine
maillet je crois qu'elle adore les
animateurs de télé je crois que la tête
chance wen avait pas faute à poil
voulait faire un ghetto un avis non donc
il vous a choisi comment ce tim burton
mais on s'est rencontré à paris voilà et
et j'avais décidé à l'intérieur de mon
être moi-même interne oui que j'aurais
guillaume sap était trop difficile de re
devenir comédien après avoir été
réalisateur
elle est bien celle là question est les
meilleurs temps du pardon
guillaume sap était difficile de re
devenir comédien après avoir été
réalisateur si c'est vrai que ça n'a pas
été facile parce qu'au départ moi je
suis quoi je suis comédien donc je joue
des rôles le texte n'est pas de moi et
tout d'un coup il a fallu celle inverse
mais non mais c'est l'envers non mais
voilà c'était mais c'était très agréable
parce que tout d'un coup on est plus
qu'un personnage a way à s'occuper et
puis jetés j'avais pas envie
enfin j'avais peur en tout cas de me
retrouver sur un plateau et avoir envie
de me mêler parce que je me suis dit si
ça arrive à ce moment là il faut que
j'arrête le métier d'acteur et au
contraire j'ai retrouvé tout le plaisir
de de ne faire que ça il me laisser
emmener par un metteur en scène et
c'était très chouette c'est une bonne
réponse à un temps pensé à ce moment là
qu'il a perdu son rasoir définitivement
c'est sur le film il joue dans narcos
voilà darko de tristan aurouet et gilles
lellouche
c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui tient
narcoleptique voilà et cataplexie
kennedy d'or tout le temps pas tout le
temps non pas tout le temps au nom il
s'endort comme ça n'importe où oui il
s'endort suite à des à des grosses
émotions c'est à dire des colères ou des
joies intenses
voilà c'est une comédie avec benoît
poelvoorde avec françois berléand devait
retrouver jean pierre cassel léa drucker
sa breitman un plein plein d'acteurs
formidables commence le 22 septembre le
tournage exactement il faut être prêt je
sais qu'ici je tire dessus je fais tout
ce que je veux mais catherine me dit que
ma fille via leurs griots merci
catherine bien alors vous savez donc le
pitch du film s'était pas cap
donc on va vous faire une interview t'es
pas cap
[Musique]
attention alors guillaume t'es pas cap
de l'embrasser sur la bouche là
maintenant non absolument pas cap
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord la
première c'est parce que je suis acteur
dans le jeu ça dans un film
ah oui et la deuxième raison c'est que
j'ai ma charmante chéri amoureuse qui
est qu'ils n'aimeraient pas ça et je
comprendrais ah oui tu fais qu'un cinéma
arrivé à la pénétration c'est bien celle
du but suisse a évolué marion t'es pas
cap de flinguer ta carrière en acceptant
taxi 4
mais je sais pas ça dépend ce qui me
confère de dans gmac a pas de scénario
dans taxi toute façon mieux les
compteurs
scénario
mais bon
20 excusez moi mais il ya des gens à qui
ça fait plaisir c'est guillaume tépacap
de faire une bonne pour y abat fils
une vanne pourrie au nom non non non
mais c'est impossible de lui faire une
bonne pour y être pourquoi basculer une
répartie de malades voient même pour
cacher ton signifie bouc a ceremony t'es
pas cap de ses pairs en même temps je
vois les photos valent quand t'es pas
cap de chanter un truc là justin as il
avait en france 1 quand j'aurai bientôt
des francs 50 ah si j'avais de france 1
quand j'aurai bientôt trois francs 55
ans
j'avais 4 ans
tu as vu quand même bientôt le temps
joue bravo
succès
vous n'étiez pas possible merci
chanter devant tout le monde comme ça
c'est vrai c'est un peu comme un tube
moi je serais prêt à signer à lahti
guillaume t'es pas cap de faire un film
porno site avec ça pour nourrir ses
enfants
si j'avais que ça pendant mes enfants je
pourrais faire autre chose pourrait
nourrir quand même que tu fais un sas
récul que ça ouais quoi d'autre voulez
faire moi je sais pas je peux faire
plein de trucs 24g des caisses à rungis
primequal un maquis des charges mais un
joli 6
genève au compteur il a quand même eu
c'est dommage que je relève aucun cap là
bas là je sais pas on va voir en tous
cas moins gourmande elle rollin je ferai
un film de cul s'il faut oui pour
nourrir mes enfants
ouais là pour l'instant j'en ai pas donc
je suis je suis enfant dans un film de
cul peut-être tu peux faire des enfants
ont trouvé une solution moi je t'ai pas
capté pas cap de mourir pour une idée
non je pas cap
même greenpeace si je suis cap t'es pas
cap de t'adresser à ta femme la face
caméra si vous la caméra là lavialle
rouge lévis ce que tu penses vraiment
d'elle je dis ce que tu penses vraiment
vas-y je t'aime ma picchu
jeunes enfants il ya une simulation
cette fois
et maintenant on passe à tout le monde
s'en mêle
donc les mails de la semaine stéphane
jacquet de genève qui nous dit lors de
l'émission du 6 septembre
lio visiblement ému a refusé de
s'exprimer sur la mort de son amie marie
trintignant mais pourquoi at elle
accepté de le faire sur tf1
le lendemain dans le 7 à 8 et sur canal+
dans l'indie investiguer de moi là
pourquoi en tous les cas on a reçu
beaucoup de mails sur cette affaire de
lio marion de jean de bordeaux
que se passe-t-il dans les loges de tout
le monde en parle dit elle que font les
invités est-ce qu'on peut venir
non non non cessé de mégots mais
beaucoup de mails pour regretter le vert
du décor ça commence énormément décrivez
nombreux je crois qu'on a reçu 400 ml je
crois qu'on va te faire changer avant la
fin de l'année moi j'ai vu du jaune mois
mais libéré qu'elle est laide et donc tu
regrettes sever tuerie qui vous le dire
publiquement
oui je les regarde mais qu'est ce que je
fasse mon meilleur je regrette je vais
je regrette
voici annie lemoine
[Musique]
allié moins de bonsoir alors annie
lemoine vous êtes journaliste effet
pendant 15 ans les infos d'abord à la
radio ensuite à la télé dans un npa à
l'époque grande époque de canal+
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans la bande à
ruquier vous êtes à la radio sur europe
1 et à la télé sur france 2 voilà ont
publié un livre aujourd'hui un livre qui
s'appelle en clair comme à la télé chez
ram c'est alors qu'on était petit quand
j'étais enfant vous disiez je serai
journaliste ou rien c'est vrai c'est
vrai j'avais vraiment envie d'être
journaliste en vie déclenchés par
françois giroux qui écrivaient des
éditos piquant dans l'express et mon
père étaient abonnées l'express et
j'avais envie de devenir journaliste
parce qu'elles n'étaient simplement
c'était une vraie vocation
et dès que vous êtes allez faire votre
premier reportage c'est un déraillement
vous avez compris vous seriez jamais
grand reporter ouais je crois que
j'étais trop sensible c'est vrai j'étais
ému par ce déraillement une chaussure
qui traînait sur les rails et je me suis
dit mon dieu le titre a perdu la
chaussure il va jamais descendre sur le
quai d'après ou cette femme à l'intense
épouvantable et j'étais déjà non j'étais
aussi c'est peut-être pour ça trop
sensible oui alors vous raconter
effectivement dans ce livre toute votre
vie vous raconter l'admiration que vous
aviez effectivement pour françoise
giroud votre premier papier à ouest
france
votre arrivée à paris au cfj votre carte
de presse
vous vous croyez que ça intéresse les
gens quand on vous le raconter tout ça
d'accord tel que vous le formule et là
j'en doute
non mais moi je voulais du journaliste
j'ai tout fait pour y arriver
d'autres s'étaient titienne cesser et je
crois que c'est ça surtout c'est
l'histoire d'un rêve c'est ne laisser
personne décider à votre place de ce qui
vous est important c'est ça que j'ai
voulu raconter dans ce bouquin et bien
sûr aussi j'ai parlé de ce que j'avais
rencontré plein de gens de la télévision
la télé beaucoup la voit de l'extérieur
la partie immergée de l'iceberg mais
savent pas comment ça se passe à
l'intérieur
ouais mais vous raconter comment
philippe gildas a refusé de vous engager
à europe 1 où c'est vrai c'est vrai j'ai
pas eu la chance d'être reçu par gildas
en a juste envoyé imaginez quand même
année moi je vous aime beaucoup vous le
savez mais si tous les gens qui sont
refusés par gildas en font un bouquin ça
va être terrible
non non mais ça c'est trois mois dans le
bouquin oui ces trois mots enfin bon
radio monte carlo vous racontez votre
travail de nuit
oui enfin je raconte en trois mots non
c'est pas ça
mais c'est vrai que les journalistes qui
font de la radio leur ambition c'est de
faire le 8 heures le matin et que ça
exige une vraie discipline se lever à 3
heures tous les jours ceux qui font le
petit matin et que c'est une ambiance
particulière les gens qui travaillent la
nuit ça crée des liens c'est un climat
particulier des choses extraordinaires
ah si un jour vous raconter un truc
incroyable il ya il ya un journaliste
qui vous demandaient chercher un café ou
lui rapporter le café il vous tape sur
les fesses en dix ans merci petit cul
non mais non mais non mais ça vous
paraît peut-être anodin mais c'est pour
dire qu'il ya 20 ans à l'époque et les
plateformes dans les rédactions et il y
avait une sorte il fallait il fallait se
battre parce que les places étaient
chères ce n'est pas évident et que oui
il y avait faute à une sorte de comme ça
tu droit de cuissage les mecs étaient
très mais ça vous choque pas vous mais
chose est sûre ce n'était pas si facile
que ça et que ce type qui effectivement
a donné une claque au milieu de l'action
dans lé merci petit cul ça m'a
déstabilisé je me suis dit bon moi si je
lui met pas la même claque au même
endroit avec un pas de quoi petit cul
bien sonores et ben je vais perdre un
peu moins nada comme chez pas mam la
respectabilité ma crédibilité ça
commençait là fallait mener un petit
combat quand même c'était pas et c'était
pas évident c'est comme quand jean
claude van damme avait voté oui souvenez
parlant de ça on va parler pendant des
mois
1 c'est quand vous donniez quand vous
donniez la composition du gouvernement
balladur
et j'habite inexcusable quand il a voté
bah oui parce que c'était en plein en
plein d'infos comme ça et je crois qu'il
avait pris il avait pris les choses quoi
en tout cas du coca c'est sûr et il
s'est penché vers le micro comme sa
pauvreté donc à robien sonore et bien
volontaire et ça m'a juste choquée mais
parce que gt gt je suis une fille bien
élevée quoi c'est tout alors vous
raconter aussi quand vous travaillez
pierre lescure donc vous dites qu'il a
enrhumé vous êtes sûr que c'était l'om
non non il a été vraiment rue mais il
avait une boîte de kleenex a coûté en
danger pas enquêter mais je crois que
non c'était un rhume vraiment qu'est ce
que tu avais de la coke dans les kleenex
bout refusé de coucher avec lui ouais
pourquoi parce qu'à l'époque j'étais
amoureuse du jeune animateur vedette de
la station
ouais je peux pas être à la fois que
l'animateur vedette est le patron et là
il ya un scoop un énorme scoop dans
votre livre annie lemoine à la mort de
simone signoret vous débarquez à la
rédaction avec des croissants et vous
dites je voudrais apporter des
croissants c'est énorme dans l'est
d'angers dont vous allez changer ça j'ai
vu ça j'ai refermé
je me suis dit pourquoi vous ne parlez
pas des interviews de lescure et bruce
lee qui sont vachement intéressant là
vous prenez des extractions vrai je
pense que j'ai trouvé dans le bon gars
alors j'en prends un autre lie à giscard
cette fois pour la c'est important il ya
giscard un jour vous demandez à giscard
s'il a bien dormi
pas du tout c'est lui qui me demandent
si j'ai bien dormi et pourquoi c'est
amusant parce que giscard je le
rencontre dans un train juste après la
défaite des présidentielles là encore
parler nulle part et moi je vais couvrir
les élections à chanonat où ils doivent
voter pour les législatives
et je vois ce type est dans le train
avec sa femme anne aymone et je parle
avec lui pendant une demi heure dans un
dans un compartiment et on y pour la
première fois il envie de parler
peut-être et il me dit juste après
m'avoir demandé d'éteindre mon magnéto
parce qu'il a vu que j'avais un petit
magnéto et ils parlent librement il me
dit moi c'est juste car qu'il parle la
première fois que j'ai imaginé que je
pouvais être battu aux présidentielles
c'est quand je dis ouais c'est quand
j'ai vu que coluche je faisais ce score
là bon bah c'est amusant savoir que
giscard c'est dit au mois de décembre
dans l'élection et ce type là le petit
que le petit clown l'aï ça veut dire que
la france est prête à faire un peu
n'importe quoi et donc voilà et
simplement le lendemain il me dit ne
vous levez pas trop tôt parce que je
vais voter après la messe et quand il me
revois le lendemain bureaux de vote ils
me demandent si j'ai bien dormi et alors
là ce qui est extraordinaire tu vois
c'est à dire le présent la public qui
demande à annie lemoine serait bien
dormi les autres journalistes qui sont
avec vous sont médusés par ça ça c'est
vrai c'est dans le bouquin sont mieux
d'usiné toit ce qui méduse
les journalistes français quand même bah
oui bah oui parce que ils sont là depuis
8 heures le matin et moi j'ai attendu
après la messe de 11,1 et donc ça fait
un peu voilà mais vous refusez d'écrire
un papier sur cette histoire oui parce
que j'ai donné ma parole je lui ai dit
que je crée pas de papiers sur lui j'ai
dormi non sur ce qu'on avait dit pendant
une demi-heure dans le
dans leurs conversations qu'on avait eue
dans le train alors on passe à la
rencontre avec françoise giroud était
attaché à l'infraction
bah oui c'est la personne qui m'a donné
envie de faire ce métier donc oui quand
christine ockrent a sorti son livre ça
vous a énervé oui parce qu'elle n'a pas
fait du bon travail mais je promets de
revenir là dessus parce que j'ai suffire
à vous en avait déjà parlé voudrait que
ce soit édité après sa mort l'automne
dernier il m'a dit oui je sais voyez
plein de gens c'est normal mais je ne
vous demande une chose c'est que ce soit
publié après maman ce titre je vais en
émoi que 6000 faut dire qu'elle
s'inquiétait parce que des proches je
vais raconter les questions que vous
posiez comment vous y preniez elle avait
des doutes d'ailleurs elle exprime ses
doutes dans son journal posthume
après ça c'était bien fait c'est déjà ne
vois pas de quel doute à quel doute vous
faites allusion puisqu'elle en avait
bien fait de céder à l'amitié elle
s'interroge elle sait pas quel type de
livret vais écrire et qui il aurait pu
demander à avoir quelques éléments non
pas du tout c'est le coûteront
journaliste et je vais vous trouverez
acharné sur la rigueur sur sur la
liberté de faire pour demander une chose
aussi aussi vulgaire aussi mesquines et
donc je crois que c'est une erreur j'en
comprends les raisons affectives et et
pour serre ne mets pas ça sur le terrain
c'est une profession des records lui dis
moi encore une fois international
renoueront salaires et jorge martinez
catane et de son livre alors laissons
parler on a dû aller lui répondit oui
vous dites que françois giroux et mais
le journalisme de chair et d'os vous un
certain d'une chose à la fin de ce
bouquin c'est que vous préférez les os
c'est clair ahmed avait fait adopter
façon d'allier à sous la ceinture vous
avez fait du voici kristinia pas point
de vue il n'y a pas d' enquête c'est à
la gauche devra composer moi parler
c'est un collage de propos recueillis en
de déjeuner en ville est extrait de
propre livre de françoise ans attendait
quand de votre part vous une journée de
qualité à autre chose madame au cra un
tel compliment
nous on est parfaitement je vais prendre
un exemple dès le début du livre le ton
est donné
vous dites on disait alors là on disait
qu'elle volait dans les boutiques de
luxe des foules à vous raconter ça qu
elle piquait des fullerènes et parfums
et vous dites alors pour éviter le
scandale y avait quelqu'un de l'express
qui passait derrière qui faisait des
chèques et zou à l'express non madame je
n'ai ni may day mais quand vous exhumé
jagr est assez moyenne ces derniers
envers les gens qui ont vécu et qui ont
travaillé miné et quand vous et que je
ne savais pas que j'étais dans un
tribunal et patronat tribunal douch est
revenue chez ruquier avec les gens senna
maxime intelligente mais interné on n'a
pas grand
[Applaudissements]
a lyon ça chauffe et sur lâché laurent
c'est vrai mais il y avait eu un tour de
chauffe en europe à la veille c'est pour
ça qu'on était très 1 1 mais je regrette
parce que en fait ça lui a fait beaucoup
de publicité et j'aurais juste lui dû
lui poser une seule question pourquoi
tant de tant de haine ça ressemble à un
règlement de comptes ce bouquin voilà
c'est tout c'est tout mais j'ai pas
changé d'avis sur le livret ceux qui ont
aimé françois dès qu'ils ont connue ne
l'ont pas reconnu dans ce portrait là au
vitriol vous avez quelque chose à dire
avec les sinois crainte là bas je lui
écris donc elle est reçue mal être après
tout ça et c'est peut-être lui dire que
je prépare sa bio à aux craintes la
biographie non autorisée ça commence par
il paraît que j'agis j'espère que ça
vous plaira davantage que celui là tirer
ensuite il ya une paix a donc je fais
tout boucle à la wii ensuite eh oui
j'aimerai quand on perd ensuite il ya
une paix a donc avec des stars à un
culte avait avec il faut pas trop parler
d'un faux ouais comme c'est gallas qui
un jour va et vient sur le plateau qui
demande expressément à ce qu'on ne parle
pas d'un faux l'information parce
qu'elle se sent pas à l'aise dans un
coeur de l'actualité tout ça mais c'est
pas efficace pour le coup c'est elle qui
est bonne chanteuse en un culte non j'ai
pas dit ça du tout non c'est des gens
qui ont peu envie de parler d'un faux je
respecte tout à fait bien sûr comme
patricia kaas vaincu est une très bonne
chanteuse vient des bons moments aussi
dans votre livre il ya le festival de
cannes où vous sortez du martinez avec
deux gardes du corps n'ont n'a oublié
cette époque là c'est pas les gardes du
corps qui sont importantes mais c'est
vrai que c'était une époque de triomphe
absolu pour canal ce qu'on a un peu
perdu de vue aujourd'hui je dirais oui
c'est vrai il y avait plus de monde
pendant festival de cannes place devant
le plateau de nulle part ailleurs que
sur les marches
à mes yeux les projections c'est un oui
parce que la télévision avait déjà pris
tout pouvoir
et puis à deux greffes aussi vous parler
d'alain de greef or lui il a eu cette
phrase malheureuse à votre sujet annie
lemoine ne me fait pas rêver
c'est vrai c'est ce qu'il a dit et pour
s'excuser parce qu'il l'a dit
publiquement dans libération il mangeait
des fleurs pendant 15 jours après c'est
une sorte de déni ouais c'est pas sympa
quoi de dire ça va bien oui mais c'est
pas forcément quelqu'un de bien pour ça
dans ta gueule
bien et puis vous quitter canal donc
avec quelques rêves quelques ambitions
mais vous dites j'ai pas soumis prendre
à canal+ ont été portées par l'image de
la chaîne est vraiment très protégé que
quand je sortais de là pour aller comme
c'était mon ambition dans les plus
grandes chaînes pour faire autre chose
tour de l'information d'ailleurs et ben
si vous ne savez pas comment vous y
prendre dans ce milieu là c'est fini
c'est implacable et moi je ne savais pas
comment faire don mais j'ai appris par
vous revoyez lescure à ce moment là un
entretien ses violons avec les autres
sortez un peu déçu 27e cette discussion
avec lescure au café de flore oui parce
que j'ai voulu faire c'est retourner
voir les acteurs principaux de canal que
lescure rousselet parce que pour leur
demander parce que moi j'ai suivi le
feuilleton canada prend des deux parties
et tous ceux qui étaient aussi les nuls
et ses atouts sont à regarder ton c'est
essayer de comprendre pourquoi canal
était en train de 200 euros donc quand
je vois lescure j'essaie de comprendre
qui a fait la faute
où ça s'est passé et je pose la question
dans le livre c'est une anecdote je
crois que décidément kerry tu n'arrives
pas à vendre bien ce livre je sais pas
si c'est vachement bien
non mais c'est intéressant savoir ce
type il y les rues ici s'expliquer mais
il n'a pas dit grand chose
il a joué au blind test et ouais il est
très bon mais quelques mois après mois
j'ai vu un type là il ya lescure qui
était encore ko et comment ne pas l'être
il est illettré en haut d'une tour il a
dirigé canal pendant des années c'est
sans aucun doute ours est mauvais c'est
sincère avec un coup de pied au derrière
il est sonné et quand je le vois je lui
demande de s'expliquer ou es ce que vous
avez commis l'erreur hills et il se pose
la question et lui même il dit où est ce
que j'ai merdé et il me répond moi qui
suis doué pour les castings là en
choisissant messier me suis fait [ __ ]
voilà [ __ ] le mot est dans vos
démarches
c'est lui qui voyait son dossier je me
suis fait bien ensuite alors on passe du
tunnel de chavanne tout le toutim vous
retrouvez chef de rayon comme vous dites
à à combien ça coûte
et puis à ce scandale sur france 2 donc
une émission de notre ami arthur qui
était complètement bidonné en fait non
non pas du tout ça j'ai retranché
d'ailleurs ah bon c'était une émission
diffusée sur france 2 en septembre 95 à
l'époque où jean pierre elkabbach était
président de france télévisions une
rumeur très vite après la diffusion du
magazine que je présentais dont j'avais
pas la stabilité mais je le veux
présenter une rumeur a tout de suite a
jailli pour dire il ya un portage qui
épisode qui est bidonné
ce n'était qu'une rumeur le reportage
été réalisée par aziz zemouri ancien
journaliste au nouvel observateur à qui
j'ai posé la question les yeux dans les
yeux est ce que tu as triché
c'était un reportage sur les ventes
d'armes en banlieue parisienne il m'a
dit non je te jure que non
voilà ça jamais été tranché sur le fond
ouais mais c'est une histoire où elle
qui m'a coûté cher très cher alors un
jour je vais en parler chez michel
denisot vous apprêtez à balancer sur la
halle kabbaj et heureusement marc
olivier fogiel qui à l'époque était
l'assistant de michel denisot vous donne
un bon conseil
ferme ta gueule et bien oui dans sa
bouche c'était sincère je pense il
pensait que à la télévision c'était bien
de faire comme ça et je pense que lui ça
sont ce principe là adaptés à son cas
lui a parfaitement réussi pour moi non
parce que ce jour là je me suis perdu de
vue et ne pas avoir été sincère sur le
plateau de denisot ce jour là ça m'a
sama samaoui ça m'a coûté cher
je me suis perdu je viens vous disiez ça
parce que je pense qu'il faut toujours
dire ce qu'on a envie de dire mais pas
deux
dire entre entre cinéma vous adorez tout
c'est marrant d'ailleurs le cinéma c'est
génial donner c'est vrai c'est
extraordinaire
les images sont tous frères
non mais je crois que la différence
c'est qu'on n'a pas forcément besoin
d'aller écrire un bouquin où on peut se
le dire en laisse coi
mais la raison de pas où je pense que
c'est bien
non sérieusement que de regretter ne pas
avoir été franche dernier le cab âge que
vous rencontrez quelque temps plus tard
en compagnie de drucker il vous à
remercier de votre manque d'audace jean
pierre elkabbach il a dit qu'il avait
clairement une responsabilité dans la
dendre dans l'échec de la preuve par
l'image c'est quelqu'un qui avait mis
les mains directement dans le sommaire
du magazine alors qu'il n'avait pas à le
faire ils étaient présentes france
télévisions et il nous a fait nous
planter et nous a fait aller dans le mur
directement parce qu'ils avaient peur
tout simplement qu'aucun que voici sorte
à l'époque enfin sur sa vie privée
elkabbach elkabbach mais oui mais oui
c'est vrai dire les infos on va ensuite
alors c'est un peu difficile c'est une
période que j'ai connu aussi vous êtes
au placard cette traversée du désert et
vous bossez avec de la rue et là il se
passe aussi un truc assez extraordinaire
un jour il vous dit tu sais annie tu
peux m'appeler jean luc et anuman crois
que il blague
ben non non mais oui de la rue qu'à
monter maintenant sa société réservoir
prod aime bien que ses collaborateurs
l'at-elle président voilà et moi je le
connais depuis canal comme le camp je le
retrouve il me dit il me dit mais tu
peux m'appeler jean luc et jeu je
pensais que c'était une plaisanterie
mais en fait pas du tout je crois que le
roi me faisais une faveur l'avaient pas
compris à ce moment là et puis voilà
non à s'annoncer l'orage parce que ça
c'est pas très bien c'est pas mal à se
mettre tout le monde à dos comme ça il
ya eu des moments de plaisir et des mois
bien bien ensuite un bon ça peut être
c'est plus sympa avec laurent ruquier
est la radio la télé au théâtre quel
bilan vous faites de ce quart de siècle
du bien génial génial beaucoup plus
heureuse aujourd'hui qu'avant et j'ai
beaucoup appris et c'est une expérience
absolument intransmissible traitement
chacun son chemin et quel bilan vous
fait cette interview l'un j'ai du mal
j'ai du mal à vous cernez je sais pas
c'était plutôt mal engagé je dois dire
je vous ai trouvé assez agressif et
voulant casser le livre au départ et
puis sur la fin à six et sur la fin un
peu mieux tiré
c'est sympa de m'avoir invité
c'est déjà bien je suis contente d'avoir
vu l'émission de l'intérieur voilà est
ce que vous pensez de ce ver ces
pistaches et pour le teint s'est pas
formé formidable là même les invités se
plaignent ça fait plus
messier
[Musique]
on continue avec la télé voici géraldine
maillet
[Musique]
et
voilà notre éditeur est à côté de vous
il est quand même formidable ce fait là
et beigbeder n'ont pas trop comment ça
va être contente d'être là alors vous
êtes une hauteur et vous avez déjà
publié trois romans une rose pour
manhattan
chez flammarion un amoureux silence chez
flammarion
trois jours pour rien chez balland mais
aujourd'hui publié prime time chez
flammarion
voilà alors en fait de 1991 à 1999 vous
avez été mannequin vous avez jamais été
vraiment top modèle gsm ou à des
catalogues de la redoute des trucs comme
ça non parce que j'étais trop grande je
fais 1 m 82 donc le catalogue qu'il faut
être beaucoup plus petits le faisait
alors peut-être non plus non non je
faisais non j'ai fait pas mal de défilé
puis j'ai bien vécu dans mon métier
comme ça marchait pas je vais décider
d'écrire dans exactement voilà c'est
moche c'est malandain sait très bien
pourquoi de naissance bon j'ai fait un
livre par le viticulture ça donne pas
envie d'acheter alors donc pour votre
premier roman tu beaucoup de presse le
deuxième un petit peu passé inaperçu
c'est ça sauf que j'étais invité chez
vous voilà et voilà toute l'histoire
mesdames messieurs géraldine maillet
était invité tout le monde en parle
elle avait prévenu ses amis sa famille
sa grand mère ça allait se faire faire
une belle permanent d'agir à faire les
ongles chez la coiffeuse de tout ça et
la veille
qu'est ce qui se passe là-bas et
géraldine mais j'ai un appel de
catherine barma qui m'annonce que il ya
un invité en trop et je suis obligé de
sauter puisque je suis la moins connue
est sans doute la moins intéressante
catherine me dis que c'est paru à 13 ans
catherine dit nous déniche iv
mais bon c'est catherine dit que les
écrivains comme vous elle les appelle
pas elle même l effet appelé par des
assistantes m'écouter alors peut-être
que c'était une assistance mais moi j'ai
le souvenir d'avoir lu catherine barma
au téléphone donc on est là bien la
sensibilité de catherine barma bien et à
ce moment là votre monde s'écroule c'est
un cauchemar qui commence pour vous
disons qu'une petite frustration trouvé
ça très injuste j'ai trouvé ça pas
élégant et donc ça m'a un petit peu
énervé 1
et donc j'ai commencé à faire une
fixette sur vous et je vous ai regardé
tous les jours à la télévision durant
ces bouquets la vérité je sais pas alors
alors il est obsédé par moi avec mes
questions quand je t'emmène commenté
l'assistant pas me répondre c'est à 4h
et les caisses que laurent qu'est ce que
tu veux que je te dise je sais pas
qu'elle avait prises jours à venir
c'est tellement
ça donne envie de route les tiens donc à
partir de là effectivement comment sial
à partir de là vous commencez à être
obsédé par moi en fait une vraie une
vraie fixette sur moi mais je vous
regarde tous les jours pendant une heure
et demie arrêtera tribaux sur
paris-première voir qui vous invitais
qui est digne de vos plateaux je regarde
tous les samedis soirs et je ne
comprends pas pourquoi moi je n'ai pas
le droit de venir donc voilà ça me ça
m'énerve énormément et puis je commence
à écrire comme c'est bien c'est que la
frustration finalement donne déjà servi
à quelque chose
vous êtes un livre qui est formidable
mais vous êtes invité là ce soir
au québec les autres tous les cas vous
avez trouvé le pitch pour parler de la
télé ou par les animateurs télé c'est un
thriller haletant il tant de roman
choral avec en parallèle une dizaine de
personnages qui font qu'ils subissent la
télévision donc des stars du petit écran
également des anonymes comme mois d'été
les spectacles recommencer alors excusez
moi parce que ont parlé dans
l'oreillette là on disait que c'était
pas mal finalement qu'on aurait dû vous
aurez vite et n'aurait pas écrit
librairie donc tu vas un calcul à partir
merci d'avoir annulé parce que ça m'a
permis d'avoir eu alors c'est quoi le
pitch votre bouquin mais je vous dis un
thriller haletant et or de roman choral
avec en parallèle une dizaine de
personnages ceux qui font la télé ceux
qui la subissent des stars du petit
écran et des anonymes des gens qui sont
fascinés par la télé voilà alors c'est
de la fiction mais vous utilisez les
vrais noms oui c'est que c'est interdit
ça non c'est pas interdit si c'est
interdit non mais moi quand quand vous
êtes enfin quand je vous regardant la
télévision dans le même demont de mon
salon vous êtes-vous fait partie de ma
vie vous rendre vous rentrez tous les
jours non mais
vous êtes vous étiez tous les jours à la
télévision et donc je vous regarde
vraiment comme une icône contemporaine
comme on pourrait regarder d'eric où jr
finalement est d'origine
oui le méchant et donc vous êtes un
personnage de fiction donc j'ai le droit
de vous de vous faire dire un peu non
vous savez bien que c'est interdit ce
que vous avez fait non mais on s'est
renseigné on a droit mais c'est pas
frédéric non on n'a absolument pas le
droit
géraldine ne faut pas dire ça
la raison mon père et je te suis auriez
aimé que peut-être que moi que castaldi
oui arthur vous fasse un procès non mais
j'étais sûr que vous ne feriez pas parce
que je vous avais beaucoup d'humour
beaucoup de recul
êtes vous êtes des gens très
intelligents donc jamais imaginer
sérieusement
imaginez que ce soit c'est un roman avec
une géraldine maillet pédophiles
qu'est ce que vous faites et je mets au
début c'est de la fiction comme vous
dans mon livre in je parle très peu de
la de la vie intime et de la vie privée
ça reste vraiment dans la sphère
publique à part quelques trucs quand
même sur moi par exemple bas que j'ai
les poils de la [ __ ] blanc mais ça c'est
votre faute c'est parce que vous parlez
toujours depuis j'ai jamais dit que
j'avais le poil de l'année finalement on
extrapole sur votre libido vous passez
au public soit volé tout ce que vous
voulez mais c'est forcément leur masse
et la romancière quand on savait bien
voilà bien qu'on peut pas faire ça enfin
jérôme à lui bientôt je vais pas vous
attaquer mais c'est si je dit annie
lemoine par exemple non je dirais pas
thierry à lévis et sinon c'est amusant
alors aux états unis bref ce grand pays
il n'y a pas ces lois qui protègent la
vie privée des stars c'est par exemple
bret easton ellis tonelli ce que dans ce
pays libre
raconter ce qu'il veut sur leonardo
dicaprio dans glamorama jean et des
choses qui arrivent à johnny depp et c
c'est à dire que
voilà c'est peut-être aussi une
appartement où la télé prend quatre
heures par jour dans la vie des gens un
romancier peut parler de son époque
je croyais patrick parle que de quatre
heures alors que des quatre heures qu'il
ya dedans ça dans la journée c'est
intéressant 80 livres 24 heures qu'est
ce qui s'est passé hier qu'il en parle
il ya d'autres livres à écrire tu
commences à me courir sur le haricot
marquée de voir si ça vient des états
unis
c'est bien justement qu'on fait dans les
clubs anglais on interdit aux gens de
parler politique est comme ça ils
peuvent rester amis longtemps
malheureusement là j'ai peur que ça ne
soit plus le cas avant prédéry non
prétériter pas fait de politique
ensemble
en tout cas ça ça m'intéresse tiens je
travaille énormément avec des mecs bien
alors géraldine revenant revenons sur
vous à la fin du livre pour passer à
tout le monde en parle
vous vous enchaînez à vous à moi je me
passe des menottes puis j'arrive pas
elle veut absolument venir est une chose
on arrive tous les deux comme ça
enchaîner et vous dites vous voulez que
je fasse le pitch thierry oui bah fait
le d'accord alors je vous dis un
thriller haletant
un roman choral avec en parallèle une
dizaine de personnages star de la télé
star du petit écran ou illustre inconnu
ceux qui font la télé ceux qui la
subissent tout ce petit monde est
interdépendant finalement et
voilà je pense que c'est un bon pitch
mais non il ya un truc que vous dites
pas là vous le vendez à le vent très mal
excuse moi il ya un truc dans son cas
c'est qu'arthur produit une émission qui
s'appelle anne story oui qu'est
présentée par castaldi et l'histoire
c'est des vieux dans un hospice qui
meurent les uns après les autres et
c'est le dernier survivant qui a gagné
ce que vous diriez ça tout le monde
achèterez votre livre mais c'est vrai
mais il faut que je sois là oui mais ça
mérite indique michel drucker a disparu
oui mais aussi que michel je suis
partout on ne sait pas où il est en fait
il est coincé dans un ascenseur
mais dimanche après midi voilà bien
alors il est des personnages et à
castaldi donc sa nouvelle émission
effectivement elle très bien pris
d'ailleurs le roman puisque envoya son
avocat mouais une livre il a trouvé ça
très drôle et c'est marrant comme enjeu
tous les sens le catalan lui c'est le
terrifie de faire cette émission and
stories avec les gens qui meurent les
uns après les autres
il ya de quoi quand même sens et la
téléréalité poussé à son paroxysme dans
les palois qui va faire une émission il
ya des gens qui sont venus des homos et
des machos dans un bus qui s'engueulent
quand on sait que ça c'est quand on
propose ça une chaîne et qu'on l'animent
and stories c'est pas terrible mais hier
je ne désespère pas peut-être qu'un
producteur l'a racheté les droits votons
briand est en deçà de la réalité je
pense alors arthur vous dites il
ressemble à personne et personne n'a
voulu ressembler il courra que lars von
triers et une bière sans alcool et que
le dogme c'est une boîte aux mots à
rotterdam
ces deux voies oui quand je le vois dans
mon petit écran je crois finalement il
ressemble assez à ce que j'ai décrit
après il ya lui qui fait public un an
dans les émissions il ya dan questeur
pour la télé réalité
alors il prépare une émission celui d'à
qui s'appelle l'île de la répulsion et
cd très moche qui craque sur les très
vilaine
je pense qu'on va venir aussi
et finir directrice des programmes de
tf1 m6 a donné un aperçu des idées il
voudrait avoir ça je suis sûr
ouais ouais alors marié pardon oui un
quatrième qui m'a dit un truc là oui
médicaments vous n'êtes pas mal le dire
dans la durée
j'ai pas fait catalogue pourtant oui
mais on sait pas fait la redoute
important et puis après il ya une fan
qui est fan de moi je suis désolé
s'appelle marie alors ça c'est un peu
glauque ainsi la fan glauque
elle vous a fait peur elle m'a fait peur
elle se suicide aux barbituriques et aux
vieux papes un peu triste là mais elle
est fascinée par vous elle vous aime
vraiment la folie oui
finalement j'ai je ressemble assez à
marie mais non mais je vous rassure il y
aura pas de passage à l'acte parce
qu'elles se touchent la nuit en mangeant
du pâté donc je me dis quand même
ces trois lits de mon lit oui c'est vrai
que ceux touchant bouffant du papier des
mouvements non je vous rassure mais ce
que je trouve émouvant c'est que elle
vous regarde énormément et à force de
vous regarder elle arrive à vous
connaître très bien je désire foule de
trucs là mais je pense que je reçois des
gens qui fait de livres sur moi enfin
tous les cas elles gardent comme une
relique une cigarette que j'ai fumé
j'étais voilà au crystal harris toi vous
savez tout donc effectivement ses poils
du sexe blanchi par la vie par les
signatures quand j'ai baisé pendant une
semaine mais parce que c'est je trouve
que vous avez vous déjà un mari qui a
presque votre âge et je sais que ce sont
des choses qui arrivent à un certain âge
je sais c'est dommage
j'ai rencontré sur l'édition à paris
donc c'est un ancien mannequin j'ai
écrit un bouquin sur un animateur de
télévision
ça va
10 moitié voilà alors on reste dans les
bouquins écrits sur la télévision voici
gilles martin chauffier
[Musique]
à
gilles martin chauffier dont 48 ans
rédac chef à paris match sk 48 ans déjà
ça commence à s'éclaircir géraldine
légèrement huit romans deux prix un et
vous publié chez grasset un livre qui
s'appelle silence on ment c'est un roman
qui parle de la télé lui aussi de la
société de connivence et de
l'intégration des immigrés voilà alors
je vais faire l'histoire vous voulez
ouais ouais alors c'est le dernier
animateur s'appelle richard tessler qui
est une émission de samedi soir qui a
beaucoup de succès et qui s'appelle
silence on ment voilà il va inviter
l'ailier droit de l'équipe de france qui
s'appelle hassan elles gagnent et pour
ça il négocie avec le cousin de ce
hassan elles gagnent qu'isabelle moncef
et la maîtresse de ce hassan al ghad
chapelle delphine il va tomber
l'animateur de télé va tomber amoureux
de cette fille complètement amoureux et
c'est ensemble j'ai pas dévoiler la fin
l histoire mais c'est ensemble qu'ils
vont être les témoins d'un fait divers
qui révélera les vraies origines de
l'animateur voilà alors le thème du
livre c'est la télé c'est pas la télé
c'est parce que c'est un peu raisonnant
par catégorie quand il est à télé c'est
bien la télé c'est pas bien c'est le
talk show sur l'idée c'est mon héros je
voulais que ce soit vraiment quelqu'un
qui anime un talk show parce qu'au fond
je voulais que ce soit quelqu'un qui est
qui sort pas d'une famille privilégiés
qui a fait des études brillantes et qui
arrive à quelqu'un de très puissant en
france
si vous n'êtes pas vu le premier à 10
ans classé 6 à 16 ans vous êtes pas
décidé que vous allez faire l'ena ne
viendrait pas le patron du crédit
lyonnais
il n'y aurait pas premier avis mais si
vous avez été un branleur à l'école si
vous avez un petit marrant vous pouvez
très bien devenir marc olivier fogiel ou
tirèrent à dessau et vous avez vraiment
du pouvoir c'est un peu le côté très
sympathique de la télé on dit beaucoup
de mal de tête mais aussi beaucoup de
violons dire c'est finalement c'est
démocratique sert les gens qui arrivent
à être important la télé c'est pas des
gens qui ont suivi le cursus honorum
habituel des gens et qui ont le pouvoir
en france mais en même temps ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est quand même
un univers impitoyable enfin annie
lemoine ab raconté lescure c'était une
star énorme escure du jour au lendemain
il tombe il est oublié de tous et des
gens qui étaient des stars j'ai pas je
pense à
marie-ange nardi whipple ou dechavanne
dechavanne c'était une star énorme et un
jour à la télé on entend qu'il était
devenu un accident industriel
c'est un métier qui pardonne pas ouais
ça c'est le premier thème c'est la télé
dont il ya beaucoup de bouquins en ce
moment qui parle de la télé vous êtes
déjà trois oui comment ça se fait la
télé elle est assez
elle représente bien l'époque hein c'est
à dire au fond il ya quelques années on
disait le grand preuve la france à la
corruption en fait aujourd'hui tout le
monde vous dit c'est à société de
connivences alors si des connivences euh
oui ça existe quoi vous vous mariez
raconté au téléphone la semaine dernière
quand je vais inviter une histoire
extraordinaire là sur la canicule la
ccpz un bon exemple de ce que j'ai la
société de connivences c'est parce qu'on
croit quand combien une bonne vie à
cette connivence si on est des secrets
sur le cul des uns des autres qu'on ne
révèle pas c'est un homme très
particulier est qui et qui par la
société de connivences et les français
d'une certaine heure n'ont pas envie
qu'on leur raconte les histoires de
fesses de leur mini c'est pas l'heure
plus regarder la vie privée en france et
elle est protégée que les abords du
centre leclerc et les gens profondément
l'acceptent
alors c'est quoi si c'est pas sa société
c'est être devant c'est des choses qu'on
sait pour être troublante et qu'on ne
révèle pas par exemple aimé par exemple
le semaine dernière quand j'ai hérité
phone je lui disais en ce moment jean
françois mattei passe devant l'assemblée
nationale on essaie de savoir la
naissance du problème de du drame de la
canicule cet été et on explique que
l'institut de veille sanitaire avait mis
en alerte on explique les
les médecins urgentistes avait mis en
alerte on explique que le gouvernement
s'était mis en branle et qu'on
commençait en fait ça ne s'est pas passé
comme ça ces gens c'étaient les
urgentistes effectivement découvert ce
qui se passait la ville de paris haut en
bas pas du tout aux de la mairie savait
ce qui se passait et personne n'en
brayer et les ministres des fax est
arrivée à matignon il se passait rien et
jacques deray moore le réalisateur
jacques ii à ce moment là sa femme a
appelé normalement elle a appelé à 6tu
des pompes funèbres en disant est ce que
vous voyez mon mari et moi ce que je
peux prendre rendez vous et ils vont dit
non c'est impossible on est absolument
désolés on est navré mais attendez
quatre cinq six jours un peu alors et
tenez bon affolée elle appelle après la
mairie de paris en 10 ans ce qui est un
service dans ce cas-là d'urgence et puis
quoi et on ne le fait pas ils disent
même chose ils disent nous on est désolé
on est accordée et à ce moment là
seulement et c'est là que c'était de
connivence fonctionne parce que c'est là
qu'on voit comment je devais expliquer
après l appel
un copain et son copain c'est dominique
ambiel qui était le conseiller de
communication du premier ministre qui a
été producteur de cinéma producteurs de
télévision qu'elle connaisse et leur
même milieu et est ce moment-là lui
comprenant ça se renseigne et dit à ce
moment là matignon
qu'est ce qui se passe on peut même plus
entre les gens à paris et c'est ça qui
déclenche le que le lan qui fait que
l'enam ati passe à la télé bien alors
vous avez quelque chose en commun avec
frédéric beigbeder si oui tous les deux
le rôle de l'écrivain c'est de cracher
dans la soupe
puisque nous n'avons pas le pouvoir il
faut peindre ce qu'ils ont dit vous
aujourd'hui vous dites qu à une
aristocratie de la notoriété qu'il y
avait là aristocratie et finalement les
dieux de l'époque dites-vous 1 c'est
l'animateur est la star de foot et face
à eux
finalement on se ressent un petit peu
comme un eunuque dans une orgie
il faut que les écrivains ne soient plus
des dinosaures herbivores mais
deviennent des faux je trouve que les
journaux dits se permet de dire ce
qu'ils veulent l'athénée les films ya
une violence incroyable la société et
les écrivains n'y a pas de raison qu'on
soit les seuls à être les moutons
et à ne pas dire est un pas décrire la
société telle qu'elle est c'est pour ça
que dans la partie ii qui se passe en
banlieue et des choses qui sont violents
parce que c'est comme ça c'est le
troisième thème de votre bouquin c'est
plus important d'ailleurs c'est
l'intégration il ya 2 0 donc tessler
l'animateur télé dont on découvre
bientôt qu'il est d'origine beurre et
elles gagnent le footballeur l'un
l'animateur à renier ses origines donc
pour réussir il a cru bon de renier ses
origines et l'autre au contraire il
trouve son épanouissement et vous
montrer d'eux façon de s'intégrer final
oui je trouve que les beurs en france on
en à la télévision alors là pour le coup
en général en donne une image absolument
caricature apte à dire qu'à une fois que
vous avez retiré les petits
enquiquineurs dans les holdings sa botte
les ascenseurs et qui font peur aux
vielles dan une fois retirés les
minettes qui met le voile à l'école
vous avez ça fait 95% du temps de
consacrer au beurre et télévision or ces
gens ça représente même pas 1% des bleus
la plupart des beurs c'est des gens qui
sont parfaitement intégrés qui
travaillent qui ont des boulots moi je
m'appelle soeur qui héberge et mais nous
et qui sont beurre j'ai eu plein de
bahia partout à tous les niveaux et qui
réussissent très bien et je voulais
avoir je voulais que le lille montrent
des beurs parfaitement intégrés c'était
ça le point de départ numéro un du truc
ensuite il se trouve que les deux vont
être en rivalité pour une femme qui ils
vont donc un matin un jour assister le
héros du ce qui vous ressemblent dirar
des souliers un peu comme tirer leçon
raccompagne la fille il l'a raccompagnée
assisté une bavure et la bavure pour
être assez vite réglé est ce que est ce
que parce que mais la question de savoir
si est ce qu'elle est exclu le prof a
été agressée par trois jeunes beurs où
ils ont été écrasés par l'un des flics 1
et lui il est là il pourrait le dire
simplement comme il ne veut pas dire
qu'ils libèrent tous le tout le livre à
des barres va partir de là ça va faire
un saab ça va bloquer ce set a vu l'a
pas volé sortez lui refuse son passé
parce qu'il adore la france il pense que
pour s'intégrer la changer son nom et
s'appeler hicham tesla 1000 venues
richard raisner
et il dit au fond on fait pas l'amour
avec une vieille dame parce qu'elle
était jeune elle est donc la grande
culture musulmane il s'en fiche et le
joueur de foot lui au contraire dit au
contraire aider
l'intégration se passerait beaucoup
mieux en france si les français
n'avaient pas l'impression que les beurs
viennent tous d'un milieu de dunes et de
cailloux et donc il faut enseigner qu'il
ya une immense civilisation musulmane et
qu'il peut aider par exemple est
stupéfait quand les joueurs de foot il
va jouer un jour à istanbul et découvre
que l' empire ottoman a été moins quatre
siècles le plus grand empire européen
dit mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on nous
enseigne pas ça pourquoi est-ce qu'on
n'a pas le droit nous aussi d'avoir une
fierté sur nos origines sur notre
culture
marc-edouard voix c'est une très bonne
émission parce que justement tu vous
avez bien fait ressortir toute toute la
pourriture allemande la de l'occident
1,1 et 2,7 occidentalisme surtout qui
d'un côté croit quand on peut dénoncer
les choses tout en y participant et en
étant parmi les plus collabo que qu'ils
soient en fait il était surveille
gilles martin je fais ici lancement
s'est évitée chez grasset les messieurs
alors il ya pile invité le jeune il
invité là qui claquent in order ans
c'est l'heure des nouveaux talents et ça
s'appelle tout le monde en rêve le
newcomer de ce soir s'appelle thomert 6
les prix révélation festival juste pour
rire le comique qui monte voici demeure
sisley
merci merci merci s'est ouvert ses bras
bonsoir thierry merci de m'avoir invité
c'est super plaisir
moi j'ai bien mater j'ai bien ma télé
mission de ma loge tout ça et ça m'a un
petit peu remué parce que on a beaucoup
parlé d'eux on a beaucoup parlé des
états unis on a beaucoup parlé du
moyen-orient et du problème
israélo-palestinien tout ça et tu vois
moi ça me touche particulièrement parce
que parce que ma mère est juive et mon
père est arabe et ils sont un petit peu
en guerre en ce moment donc voilà donc
voilà c'est donc je suis juif et arabe
à mon avis mes parents m'ont eu
uniquement bon père chier je suis juif
et arabe je sais pas si vous imaginez le
nombre d'ennemis que je peux avoir sur
terre non de personnes qui me détestent
quand même me connaît sait pas facile
d'être juifs et arabes a vraiment pas
mais parce que 50% arabe pour un juif
c'est de toute façon déjà trop est un
pur sang juif pour un arabe c'est juste
impensable
mes parents voulaient m'appeler shlomo
ben youssouf a les deux familles
n'étaient pas d'accord finalement c'est
l'onu qui a décidé c'est pas facile
d'être juifs et arabes a vraiment pas
surtout en france et parce que moi à
chaque fois que je passe une soirée avec
des copains et qui se met à raconter des
blagues
[ __ ] il ya deux blagues sur trois qui
me font pas rire
et encore j'ai eu de la chance j'aurais
pu être blonde un psychologiquement ça
m'a complètement [ __ ] la tête vraiment
moi je me suis déjà jeté des pierres
vers nous c'est vraiment c'est pas
évident c'est vraiment pas évident car
en plus avec les manifestations
pro-palestiniennes le samedi les
manifestations pro israélienne le
dimanche j'ai plus un seul week-end pour
moi c'est vraiment c'est une situation
délicate quoi sert que ça que la moitié
de ma famille est juive et et l'autre
moitié de ma famille et arabes à la
dernière fois que j'ai rendu visite à
mon nom qui m'a gardé en otage pendant
six mois je sais plus quoi faire mois
avec toutes ces conneries je sais pas
s'il faut que je sorte avec des filles
juives ou s'il faut que je sorte avec
des filles arabe
du coup sort qu'avec des françaises ma
dernière copine sa famille était très
française quand ils ont appris qu'ils
jettent et ça leur a fait deux mauvaises
nouvelles d'un coup nous sommes bien la
première fois que j'ai la première fois
que j'ai été mangé chez eux ils étaient
super gêné mais vous manger quoi alors
du couscous ou du couscous non c'était
c'était des racistes de base vraiment à
la fin du repas il me fouiller façon ça
n'a pas vraiment tenu le coup avec cette
copine parce que elle voulait pas se
convertir deux fois et pour moi c'était
vraiment important parce que je voulais
pas choisir entre les deux religions
vraiment je me suis lancé à fond dans
les deux religions j'ai passé trois ans
à traduire la torah en arabe
j'ai très vite arrêté après avec tous
trip religieux tout ça parce que je sais
pas si vous vous rendez compte mais moi
si je respecte tous les interdits de mes
deux religions le seul truc que j'aurais
le droit de faire c'est boire de l'eau
le mercredi soir après le coucher du
soleil en plus cherché à battre pendant
le ramadan c'est super chiant
merci beaucoup
à
merci à tous c'était tout en bas
[Musique]
que françois dupeyron avec omar sharif
pierre boulanger gilbert melki et ça
sort le 17 septembre
frédéric beigbeder windows 32 roi
chez grasset mesdames messieurs marc
edouard nabe printemps de feu aux
éditions du rocher
l'image a marre je devais aussi tué aux
éditions albin michel
guillaume canet marion cotillard jeunes
enfants de yann samuell ça sort le 17
septembre
aline mois en clair comme à la télé
c'est chez ram c'est géraldine maillet
prime time chez flammarion gilles martin
chauffier silence au mans chez grasset
voilà
et puis tout le monde en rêve venait de
voir thomert 6 les reporter sans
frontières pour dénoncer la répression à
cuba
reporter sans frontière organise une
soirée de lundi 29 septembre terre du
rond point des champs elysées à 20h30
avec sophie marceau catherine deneuve et
du plein m et vous tous merci c'était
vraiment pas rendez vous la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
où la terre
avec madonna
[Musique]
les auteurs
non
[Musique]
ap
ah ah
[Musique]
m
deux heures
oui
[Musique]
oh oui